[Musik]
die alten Appelle an rassischen
sexuellen und religiösen Chauvinismus an
fanatische nationalistische Inbrunst
beginnen nicht mehr zu funktionieren das
ist es was ich bin ob ich gut oder
schlecht bin ob ich etwas erreiche oder
nicht all das hat man im Laufe der Zeit
gelernt es ist nur ein Ausflug wir
können ihn jederzeit ändern es ist nur
eine Wahl keine Anstrengung keine Arbeit
kein Job kein Geld sparen mir wurde klar
dass ich das Spiel falsch verstanden
hatte dass das Spiel darin bestand
herauszufinden was ich bereits war
[Musik]
wir haben gesagt
wie wichtig es ist
den menschlichen Geist eine radikale
Revolution herbeizuführen
die Krise ist eine Krise des
Bewusstseins
eine Krise
die die alten Normen die alten Muster
die alten Traditionen nicht mehr
akzeptieren kann
[Musik]
und wenn man bedenkt wie die Welt jetzt
ist
mit all dem Elend den Konflikten der
zerstörerischen Brutalität der
Aggression und so weiter
[Musik]
dann ist der Mensch immer noch so wie er
war
[Musik]
er ist immer noch brutal gewalttätig
aggressiv
erwerbsorientiert
wettbewerbsorientiert und er hat eine
Gesellschaft nach diesem Muster
erschaffen
[Musik]
es ist kein Maß für Gesundheit
sich einer zutiefstkranken Gesellschaft
gut anzupassen
[Musik]
die heutige Gesellschaft setzt sich aus
einer Reihe von Institutionen zusammen
von politischen Institutionen
rechtlichen Institutionen religiösen
Institutionen bis hin zu Institutionen
der sozialen Klasse familiären Werten
und beruflicher Spezialisierung es ist
offensichtlich welch tiefgreifenden
Einfluss dieser traditionellen
Strukturen auf unser Verständnis und
unsere Perspektiven haben doch bei all
den sozialen Institutionen in die wir
hineingeboren werden die uns leiten und
von denen wir abhängig sind scheint es
kein System zu geben das so
selbstverständlich ist und so
missverstanden wird wie das Geldsystem
das etablierte Geldsystem nimmt fast
religiöse Ausmaße an und ist eine der am
wenigsten hinterfragten Formen des
Glaubens die es gibt wie Geld geschaffen
wird durch welche Politik ist gesteuert
wird und wie ist die Gesellschaft
wirklich beeinflusst ist für die große
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung nicht von
Interesse
in einer Welt in der ein Prozent der
Bevölkerung 40% des Reichtums des
Planeten besetzt in einer Welt in der
jeden Tag 34.000 Kinder an Armut und
vermeidbaren Krankheiten sterben und in
der 50% der Weltbevölkerung mit weniger
als 2 Dollar pro Tag auskommen müssen
ist eines klar hier stimmt etwas nicht
und ob wir uns dessen bewusst sind oder
nicht das Lebenselixier all unserer
etablierten Institutionen und damit der
Gesellschaft selbst ist das Geld daher
ist das Verständnis dieser Institution
der Geldpolitik von entscheidender
Bedeutung um zu verstehen warum unser
Leben so ist wie es ist ein Vorschlag
leider wird die Wirtschaftswissenschaft
oft mit Verwirrung und Langeweile
betrachtet endlose Ströme von
finanzsattung gepaart mit
einschüchternder Mathematik schrecken
die Menschen schnell von dem Versuch ab
sie zu verstehen
tatsache ist jedoch dass die mit dem
Finanzsystem verbundene Komplexität nur
eine Maske ist hinter der sich eine der
soziallebenden Strukturen verbirgt die
die Menschheit je ertragen hat
niemand ist hoffnungsloser versklavt als
diejenigen die fälschlicherweise glauben
sie seien frei Johann Wolfgang von
Goethe
vor einigen Jahren veröffentlichte die
US-Zentralbank die Federal Reserve ein
Dokument mit dem Titel modern money
mechanics in dieser Publikation wird die
institutionalisierte Praxis der
Geldschöpfung beschrieben wie sie von
der Federal Reserve und dem von ihr
unterstützten Netz globaler
Geschäftsbanken angewandt wird auf der
ersten Seite wird das Ziel des Dokuments
genannt der Zweck dieser Broschüre
besteht darin den grundlegendsten
Prozess der Geldschöpfung in einem
Bankensystem mit Mindestreserve zu
beschreiben anschließend wird dieser
Prozess der mindestrenserve durch
verschiedene bankbegriffe beschrieben
eine Übersetzung lautet etwa so
die US-Regierung beschließt dass sie
Geld braucht also ruft sie die Federal
Reserve an und bittet um sagen wir 10
Milliarden Dollar die Fett antwortet
sicher wir kaufen Staatsanleihen im Wert
von 10 Milliarden Dollar von ihnen die
Regierung nimmt also ein paar Papiere
malt einige offiziell aussehende Designs
darauf und nennt sie Staatsanleihen dann
bewertet sie diese Anleihen mit der
Nummer von 10 Milliarden Dollar und
schickt sie an die Fett im Gegenzug
stellen die Mitarbeiter der Fett selbst
einen Haufen beeindruckender Papiere her
nur dass sie sie diesmal fatral Reserve
Notes nennen und ebenfalls einen Wert
von 10 Milliarden Dollar angeben die
fetten nimmt dann diese Scheine und
tauscht sie gegen die Anleihen ein
sobald dieser Tausch abgeschlossen ist
nimmt die Regierung die 10 Milliarden
Dollar und zahlt sie auf ein Bankkonto
ein
mit dieser Einzahlung werden die
Geldscheine offiziell zum gesetzlichen
Zahlungsmittel und erweitern die
Geldmenge der USA um 10 Milliarden
Dollar und das war's es wurden 10
Milliarden Dollar an neuem Geld
geschaffen natürlich ist dieses Beispiel
eine für allgemeinerung denn in
Wirklichkeit würde diese Transaktion auf
elektronischem Wege erfolgen ohne das
überhaupt Papier verwendet würde
tatsächlich existieren nur drei Prozent
der US Geldmenge in physischer Währung
die anderen 97% existieren im
Wesentlichen nur im Computer
nun sind Staatsanleihen von Natur aus
Schuld Titel und wenn die Fett diese
Anleihen mit Geld kauft dass sie im
Wesentlichen aus dem Nichts geschaffen
hat verspricht die Regierung tatsächlich
dieses Geld an die Fett zurückzuzahlen
mit anderen
dieses Paradoxon wie Geld oder Wert aus
Schulden oder Verbindlichkeiten
geschaffen werden kann wird im weiteren
Verlauf dieses Films noch deutlicher
werden der Umtausch ist also erfolgt und
jetzt liegen zehn Milliarden Dollar auf
einem Geschäftskonto jetzt wird es
wirklich interessant denn aufgrund der
Praxis der Mindestreserve werden diese
10 Milliarden Dollar sofort Teil der
bankreserven
genau wie alle anderen Einlagen auch und
was die reserveanforderungen betrifft so
muss eine Bank wie in modern money
mechanics dargelegt gesetzlich
vorgeschriebene Reserven in Höhe eines
vorgeschriebenen Prozentsatzes ihrer
Einlagen hinterlegen die Studie
quantifiziert das indem sie angeht dass
die Mindestreserve Pflicht für die
meisten transaktionskonten nach dem
derzeitigen Vorschriften 10% beträgt das
heißt dass bei einer Einlage von 10
Milliarden Dollar eine Milliarde als
vorgeschriebene Reserve gehalten werden
während die anderen 9 Milliarden als
übermäßiger Reserve gelten und als
Grundlage für neue Kredite verwendet
werden können
[Musik]
nun ist es logisch anzunehmen dass diese
9 Milliarden buchstäblich aus der
bestehenden 10 Milliarden dollar-einlage
stammen das ist aber nicht der Fall was
wirklich passiert ist dass die 9
Milliarden einfach aus dem Nichts
zusätzlich zu den bestehenden 10
Milliarden Dollar Einlagen geschaffen
werden auf diese Weise wird die
Geldmenge ausgeweitet wir in der
modernen geldmechanik dargelegt zahlen
die Banken natürlich nicht wirklich
Kredite aus dem Geld aus dass sie als
Einlagen erhalten was Sie tun wenn Sie
Kredite vergeben ist die Annahme von
Schuldscheinen Kreditverträgen im
Austausch für Kredite Geld auf den
transaktionskonten des Kreditnehmers
mit anderen Worten die 9 Milliarden
können aus dem Nichts geschaffen werden
einfach weil es eine Nachfrage nach
einem solchen Kredit gibt und weil es
eine Einlage von 10 Milliarden Dollar
gibt um die reserveanforderungen zu
erfüllen nehmen wir nun an dass jemand
in diese Bank geht und sich die neu
verfügbaren 9 Milliarden Dollar leid
derjenige wird dann wahrscheinlich
dieses Geld nehmen und es auf sein
eigenes Bankkonto einzahlen
der Prozess wiederholt sich dann denn
diese Einzahlung wird Teil der Reserven
der Bank 10% werden isoliert und 90% der
9 Milliarden oder 8,1 Milliarden stehen
nun als neu geschaffenes Geld für
weitere Kredite zu Verfügung und
natürlich können diese 8,1 Milliarden
Euro ausgeliehen und wieder eingezahlt
wodurch weitere 7,2 bis 6,5 bis 5,9
Milliarden und so weiter Entstehen
dieser Zyklus aus Einzahlung
Geldschöpfung und Kreditvergabe kann
technisch gesehen bis ins Unendliche
fortgesetzt werden das durchschnittliche
mathematische Ergebnis ist dass etwa 90
Milliarden Dollar zusätzlich zu den
ursprünglichen 10 Milliarden geschaffen
werden können mit anderen Worten für
jede Einlage die jemals im Bankensystem
getätigt wird kann etwa das Neunfache
dieses Betrags aus dem Nichts erschaffen
werden
Geldsorgen bitten Sie die zuvorkommende
Bank of America um einen Krug mit
beruhigenden sofort Geld
in Form eines bequemen Privatkredits
jetzt da wir verstehen wie Geld durch
das mindestreservebankensystem
geschaffen wird drängt sich eine
logische aber schwer zu beantwortende
Frage auf was gibt diesem neu
geschaffenen Geld eigentlich seinen Wert
die Antwort das Geld das bereits
existiert das neue Geld stiehlt im
Grunde den Wert der bestehenden
Geldmenge
denn die gesamtgeltmenge wird unabhängig
von der Nachfrage nach Waren und
Dienstleistungen erhöht und wenn Angebot
und Nachfrage ein Gleichgewicht finden
steigen die Preise wodurch die Kaufkraft
jedes einzelnen Dollars sinkt dies wird
allgemein als Inflation bezeichnet und
Inflation ist im Grunde eine versteckte
Steuer für die Öffentlichkeit
was ist der Rat den man im allgemeinen
bekommt sie sagen nicht entwertet die
Währung sie sagen nicht betrügt die
Leute die gespart haben sie sagen senkt
die Zinssätze die wirkliche Täuschung
besteht darin dass wir den Wert des
Geldes verzerren dass wir Geld aus dem
Nichts erschaffen dass wir keine
Ersparnisse haben dass es aber das
sogenannte Kapital gibt meine Frage
läuft also auf folgendes hinaus wie um
alles in der Welt können wir erwarten
die Probleme der Inflation also der
Zunahme des geldangebots mit mehr
Inflation zu lösen natürlich geht das
nicht das fraktionierte Reserve System
der geldausweitung ist von Natur aus
inflationär wenn die Ausweitung der
Geldmenge ohne eine proportionale
Ausweitung von Waren und
Dienstleistungen in der Wirtschaft für
immer zu Entwertung einer Währung
ein kurzer Blick auf die historischen
Werte des US-Dollars im Vergleich zur
Geldmenge zeigt dies deutlich
in die umgekehrte Beziehung ist
offensichtlich
für einen Dollar im Jahr 1913 waren im
Jahr 2007 21 Dollar und 60 Cent nötig um
den gleichen Wert zu erreichen das ist
eine Abwertung von 96% seid bestehende
Reserve
wenn Ihnen diese Realität einer
inhärenten und fortwährenden Inflationen
absurd und wirtschaftlich selbst
zerstörerisch vorkommt halten Sie diesen
Gedanken fest denn ab so die tät ist
eine Untertreibung wenn man bedenkt wie
unser Finanzsystem wirklich funktioniert
denn in unserem Finanzsystem ist Geld
gleich Schulden
und Schulden sind Geld
hier ist eine Grafik der us-geldmenge
von 1950 bis 2006 hier ist ein Diagramm
der US-Staatsverschuldung für den
gleichen Zeitraum interessant ist dass
die Kurven praktisch identisch sind
denn je mehr Geld es gibt desto mehr
Schulden gibt es je mehr Schulden es
gibt desto mehr Geld gibt es anders
ausgedrückt jeder einzelne Dollar in
Ihrer Brieftasche wird jemandem von
jemandem geschuldet denken Sie daran
dass das Geld nur durch Kredite
entstehen kann
wenn also jeder im Land in der Lage wäre
alle Schulden zu begleichen
einschließlich der Regierung wäre kein
einziger Dollar im Umlauf
wenn es in unserem Geldsystem keine
Schulden gäbe gäbe es auch kein Geld
Marina Eckels
das letzte Mal in der amerikanischen
Geschichte wurden die Staatsschulden im
Jahr 1835 vollständig getilgt nachdem
Präsident Andrew Jackson die Zentralbank
die Vorgängerin der Federal Reserve
geschlossen hatte Jacksons gesamtes
politisches Programm drehte sich im
wesentlichen um seinen Engagement für
die Schließung der Zentralbank wobei er
erklärte die kühnen Anstrengungen die
die gegenwärtige Bank unternommen hat um
die Regierung zu kontrollieren sind nur
eine Vorahnung des Schicksals dass das
Volk erwartet sollte es sich zu einer
Fortführung dieser Institution unter der
Errichtung einer anderen wie dieser
verdünnen leider war seine Botschaft nur
von kurzer Dauer und den internationalen
Bankiers gelang es 1913 eine weitere
Zentralbank zu errichten die Federal
Reserve und solange diese Institution
existiert ist eine ewige Verschuldung
garantiert
bis jetzt haben wir die Tatsache
besprochen das Geld aus Schulden durch
Kredite geschaffen wird
diese Kredite basieren auf den Reserven
einer Bank und die Reserven werden aus
Einlagen gewonnen und durch dieses
fraktionierte Reserve System kann eine
einzige Einlage das Neunfache ihres
ursprünglichen Wertes erzeugen was
wiederum die bestehende Geldmenge
entwertet und die Preise in der
Gesellschaft erhöht unter all dieses
Geld aus Schulden erschaffen wird und
wahllos durch den Handel zirkuliert
werden die Menschen von ihren
ursprünglichen Schulden losgelöst und es
entsteht ein Ungleichgewicht in dem die
Menschen gezwungen sind um ihre
Arbeitskraft zu konkurrieren um genug
Geld aus der Geldmenge zu ziehen um ihre
Lebenshaltungskosten zu decken
so dysfunktional und rückwärtsgewandt
dies alles auch erscheinen mag es gibt
immer noch eine Sache die wir in dieser
Gleichung ausgelassen haben und das ist
dieses Element der Struktur dass die
wirklich betrügerische Natur des Systems
selbst offenbart
die Anwendung von Zinsen
wenn sich die Regierung Geld von der
Fett leiht oder wenn sich jemand Geld
von einer Bank leiht muss es fast immer
mit aufgelaufenem Zinsen zurückgezahlt
werden
mit anderen Worten fast jeder einzelne
Dollar der existiert muss irgendwann an
eine Bank zurückgegeben werden wobei
auch Zinsen gezahlt werden müssen wenn
aber das gesamte Geld von der
Zentralbank Berlin und von den
Geschäftsbanken durch Kredite
ausgeweitet wird wird nur das was man
als Prinzip bezeichnen würde in der
Geldmenge geschaffen
wo ist dann das Geld um alle Zinsen zu
decken die erhoben werden
nirgendwo es ist nicht vorhanden die
Auswirkungen sind atemberaubend denn der
Betrag der den Banken geschuldet wird
übersteigt immer die Menge des im Umlauf
befindlichen Geldes
aus diesem Grund ist die Inflation eine
Konstante in der Wirtschaft denn es wird
immer neues Geld benötigt um das
ständige Defizit zu decken das durch die
Notwendigkeit die Zinsen zu zahlen in
das System eingebaut ist das bedeutet
auch das Zahlungsausfälle und Konkurse
buchstäblich zum System gehören
und es wird immer Arme
Bevölkerungsschichten geben die den
Kürzeren ziehen
eine Analogie dazu wäre das Spiel Reise
nach Jerusalem denn sobald die Musik
aufhört bleibt jemand auf dem Trockenen
sitzen und genau das ist der Punkt der
wahre Reichtum wird vom einzelnen auf
die Banken übertragen denn wenn sie
nicht in der Lage sind ihre Hypothek zu
bezahlen nehmen sie ihnen ihr Eigentum
Weg das ist besonders ärgerlich wenn man
sich vergegenwärtigt dass ein solcher
auf jeden Fall nicht nur aufgrund der
Praxis der Mindestreserve unvermeidlich
ist sondern auch aufgrund der Tatsache
dass das Geld das die Bank ihnen
geliehen hat gar nicht legal existiert
im Jahr 1969 gab es in Minnesota einen
Gerichtsfall in dem ein Mann namens
Jerome daily gegen die
Zwangsvollstreckung seines Hauses durch
die Bank die das Darlehen für den Kauf
gewährt hatte klagte sein Argument war
dass der hypothekenvertrag von beiden
Parteien also ihm und der Bank verlangte
dass jede Partei eine legitime Form von
Eigentum für den Austausch zur Verfügung
stellt im juristischen Jargon wird das
als Gegenleistung bezeichnet
Herr daily erklärte dass das Geld in
Wirklichkeit nicht Eigentum der Bank sei
da es aus dem Nichts geschaffen wurde
sobald der Darlehensvertrag
unterzeichnet war erinnern sie sich was
die modernen geldmechaniker über Kredite
gesagt haben wenn sie Kredite vergeben
nehmen Sie Schuldscheine im Austausch an
die Reserven bleiben durch die
kredittransaktionen und verändert aber
die einlagenkredite stellen neue Zugänge
zu den gesamten Einlagen des
Bankensystems da in anderen Worten das
Geld stammt nicht aus den vorhandenen
Vermögenswerten der Banken die Bank
erfindet es einfach indem sie außer
einer theoretischen Verbindlichkeit auf
dem Papier nichts Eigenes einbringt im
weiteren Verlauf des Prozesses trat der
Präsident der Bank Mister Morgan in den
Zeugenstand und der Richter erinnerte
sich in seinem persönlichen Memorandum
daran dass der Kläger der Präsident der
Bank zugab dass die Bank in Verbindung
mit der Federal Reserve Bank das Geld
und den Kredit durch buchhalterische
Einträge geschaffen hatte das Geld und
der Kredit entstanden erst als sie es Mr
Morgan gab zu dass kein Geld oder Statut
ihm das Recht gab dies zu tun eine
rechtmäßige Gegenleistung muss vorhanden
sein und angeboten werden die
Geschworenen befanden dass es keine
rechtmäßige Gegenleistung gab sie fügten
außerdem hinzu nur Gott könne etwas
Wertvolles aus dem Nichts erschaffen
aufgrund dieser Erkenntnis wie ist das
Gericht den Antrag der Bank auf
Zwangsvollstreckung zurück und daily
behielt sein Haus die Tragweite dieser
Gerichtsentscheidung ist immens jedes
Mal wenn sie sich Geld von einer Bank
leihen sei es ein Hypotheken Darlehen
oder eine kreditkartenabbuchung ist das
Geld das ihnen gegeben wird nicht nur
gefälscht sondern auch eine
unrechtmäßige Form der Gegenleistung und
macht damit die Rückzahlung durch den
Vertragspartner und gültig da die Bank
das Geld ursprünglich nie als Eigentum
besaß leider werden solche rechtlichen
Erkenntnisse unterdrückt und ignoriert
und das Spiel des ewigen Vermögens
Transfers und der ewigen Schulden geht
weiter und das bringt uns zu der
entscheidenden Frage
warum
während des amerikanischen Bürgerkriegs
umging Präsident Lincoln die von den
europäischen Banken angebotenen hochzins
Kredite und beschloss das zu tun wofür
die Gründerväter eintragen nämlich eine
unabhängige und von Natur aus
schuldenfreier Währung zu schaffen sie
wurde green backt
kurz nach dieser Maßnahme zirkulierte
ein internes Dokument zwischen privaten
britischen und amerikanischen Banken
indem es hieß sklaverei ist nichts
anderes als der Besitz von Arbeit und
bringt die Sorge um die Arbeiter mit
sich während der europäische Plan darin
besteht dass das Kapital die Arbeit
durch die Kontrolle der Löhne
kontrolliert das kann durch die
Kontrolle des Geldes erreicht werden es
wird nicht ausreichend den Greenback
zuzulassen da wir ihn nicht
kontrollieren können die von der Federal
reser verfolgt der Politik der
Mindestreserve die sich in der Praxis
auf die große Mehrheit der Banken in der
Welt ausgeweitet hat ist in Wirklichkeit
ein System moderner Sklaverei
denken Sie darüber nach Geld wird aus
Schulden geschaffen und was tun die
Menschen wenn sie verschuldet sind sie
nehmen Arbeit an um sie zu begleichen
aber wenn Geld nur durch Kredite
geschaffen werden kann wie kann die
Gesellschaft dann jemals schuldenfrei
sein sie kann es nicht und genau das ist
der Punkt und es ist die Angst vor dem
Verlust von Vermögenswerten gepaart mit
dem Kampf mit der ständigen Verschuldung
und der dem System innewohnenden
Inflation Schritt zu halten verstärkt
durch die unausweichliche Knappheit
innerhalb der Geldmenge selbst die durch
die Zinsen geschaffen wird die niemals
zurückgezahlt werden können die den Lohn
Sklaven bei der Stange hält der mit
Millionen anderer im Hamsterrad läuft
und so ein Imperium antreibt das nur der
Elite an der Spitze der Pyramide zugute
kommt
denn für wen arbeiten sie letzten Endes
wirklich
für die Banken Geld wird in einer Bank
geschaffen und landet unweigerlich in
einer Bank sie sind die wahren Herren
zusammen mit den Konzernen und
Regierungen die sie unterstützen
physisches Sklaverei erfordert das
Menschen untergebracht und ernährt
werden die wirtschaftliche Sklaverei
verlangt dass die Menschen sich selbst
ernähren und unterbringen sie ist einer
der raffiniertesten Betrügereien zu
sozialen Manipulationen die je erfunden
wurde und in ihrem Kern ist sie ein
unsichtbarer Krieg gegen die Bevölkerung
Schulden sind die Waffe die zu Eroberung
und Versklavung von gesellschaftlichen
eingesetzt wird um Zinsen sind ihre
hauptmunition
und wären die Mehrheit sich dieser
Realität nicht bewusst ist fahren die
Banken in Zusammenarbeit mit Regierungen
und Unternehmen fort ihre Taktik der
wirtschaftlichen Kriegsführung zur
perfektionieren und zu erweitern
indem Sie neue Stützpunkte wie die
Weltbank und den Internationalen
Währungsfond gründen und gleichzeitig
eine neue Art von Soldaten erfinden die
Geburt des wirtschaftskillers
es gibt zwei Wege eine Nationen zu
erobern und zu versklaven der eine ist
durch das Schwert der andere durch
Schulden John Adams
wir die wirtschaftskiller sind
diejenigen die für die Schaffung dieses
ersten wirklich globalen Imperiums
verantwortlich sind und wir arbeiten auf
viele verschiedene Arten aber die
vielleicht häufigste ist dass wir ein
Land ausfindig machen das über
Ressourcen verfügt dass unsere Konzerne
Begehren wie etwa Öl und dann einen
riesigen Kredit an dieses Land von der
Weltbank oder einer ihrer Schwester
Organisationen arrangieren aber das Geld
geht nie wirklich an das Land
stattdessen geht es an unsere
Großkonzerne um in diesem Land
Infrastrukturprojekte zu starten
Kraftwerke Industrieparks helfen Dinge
von denen neben unseren Konzernen auch
ein paar reiche Leute in diesem Land
profitieren die aber der Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung überhaupt nicht helfen aber
diese Menschen das ganze Land bleiben
auf riesigen Schulden sitzen und zwar
auf so großen Schulden dass sie sie
nicht zurückzahlen können und das ist
ein Teil des Plans und so gehen wir die
wirtschaftskiller irgendwann zu Ihnen
zurück und sagen hör zu ihr habt viel
Geld verloren also verkauft euer Öl ganz
billig an unsere Ölfirmen erlaubt uns
eine Militärbasis in eurem Land zu bauen
oder Truppen zu Unterstützung unserer
Truppen an einen Ort in der Welt wie den
Irak zu schicken oder stimmt bei der
nächsten unabstimmung mit uns damit ihre
Stromversorgungsunternehmen privatisiert
werden und Wasser und Abwassersysteme
privatisiert und an US-Konzerne oder
andere multinationale Konzerne verkauft
werden das ist typisch für die
Arbeitsweise des Internationalen
Währungsfonds und der Weltbank man
verschuldet ein Land und die Schulden
werden so hoch dass es sie nicht
bezahlen kann und dann bietet man ihm an
diese Schulden zu refinanzieren und noch
mehr Zinsen zu zahlen und man verlangt
diese Gegenleistung die man
Konditionalität oder gute
Regierungsführung nennt was im Grunde
bedeutet dass es seine Ressourcen
einschließlich vieler seiner sozialen
Dienste seiner Versorgungsunternehmen
seines Schulsystems manchmal auch seines
Strafvollzugs seine Versicherungssystems
an ausländische Unternehmen verkauft
der Präzedenzfall für wirtschaftskiller
begann in den frühen 50er Jahren als der
demokratisch gewählte Moussa Deck der im
Iran gewählt wurde als Hoffnungsträger
für die Demokratie im Nahen Osten und in
der ganzen Welt galt er war der Mann des
Jahres im Time Magazine aber eines der
Dinge mit denen er kandidierte und die
er umzusetzen begann war die Idee des
ausländische Ölfirmen dem iranischen
Volk viel mehr für das Öl zahlen müssten
dass sie aus dem Land holten und dass
das iranische Volk von seinem eigenen Öl
profitieren sollte eine merkwürdige
Politik das gefiel uns natürlich nicht
aber wir hatten Angst das zu tun was wir
normalerweise tun nämlich das Militär zu
schicken stattdessen schickten wir einen
CIA-Agenten Kermit Rose Welt einen
Verwandten von Teddy Roosevelt und damit
ging mit ein paar Millionen Dollar
dorthin und war sehr sehr effizient in
kurzer Zeit gelang es ihm zu stürzen und
den Schaf von Iran an seine Stelle zu
setzen der dem Öl immer wohlgesonnen war
und das war äußerst effektiv
[Musik]
Bomben überfluten Tehran Armee Offiziere
rufen das musadec kapituliert hat und
sein Regime als faktischer Diktator des
Iran beendet ist
der Schar wird zu Hause willkommen
geheißen
zurück in den Vereinigten Staaten in
Washington schauten sich die Leute um
und sagten wow das war einfach und
billig damit wurde eine ganz neue Art
der Manipulation von Ländern und der
Schaffung von Imperien geschaffen das
einzige Problem mit Roosevelt war dass
er ein ausgewiesener CIA-Agent war und
wenn er erwischt worden wäre hätte das
ziemlich ernste Folgen haben können
daher wurde sehr schnell beschlossen
private Berater einzusetzen und das Geld
über die Weltbank oder den IWF oder eine
andere derartige Einrichtung zu leiten
und Leute wie mich die für
Privatunternehmen arbeiteten
einzuschleusen wenn wir erwischt würden
gäbe es also keine Konsequenzen für die
Regierung
als abends Präsident von Guatemala wurde
stand das Land unter der Kontrolle der
United Fruit company der großen
internationalen Konzerne und abends
kandidierte mit dem Slogan wir wollen
das Land dem Volk zurückgeben und als er
an die Macht kam setzte er eine Politik
um die genau das bewirken sollte die
Rückgabe von Landrechten an das Volk das
gefiel United nicht besonders gut sie
beauftragten eine Public relationsfirma
und starteten eine riesige Kampagne in
den USA um die USA das Volk die Bürger
dort die Presse der Vereinigten Staaten
und den Kongress davon zu überzeugen
dass abends eine sowjetische Marionette
sein und das wenn wir ihn an der Macht
ließen die Sowjets in dieser Hemisphäre
Fuß fassen würden zu dieser Zeit hatte
jeder große Angst vor dem roten dem
kommunistischen Terror um es kurz zu
machen aus dieser PR-Kampagne gegen die
Verpflichtung der CIA und des Militärs
hervor diesen Mann auszuschalten und das
taten wir tatsächlich wir schickten
Flugzeuge wir schicken Soldaten wir
schickten Schakale wir schickten alles
um ihn auszuschalten und wir haben ihn
ausgeschaltet und sobald er aus dem Amt
entfernt war hat er neuer Mann der nach
ihm Mann die Macht kam im Grunde alles
für die großen internationalen Konzerne
wiederhergestellt einschließlich United
Fruit
Ecuador wurde viele viele Jahre lang von
us-freundlichen Diktatoren regiert die
oft relativ brutal waren als beschlossen
wurde eine wirklich demokratische Wahl
abzuhalten kandidierte raimerodos für
das Amt er sagte sein Hauptziel als
Präsident sei es dafür zu sorgen dass
die Ressourcen Ecuadors zu Unterstützung
des Volkes eingesetzt würden und er
gewann mit überwältigender Mehrheit mit
mehr Stimmen als je ein anderer in
Ecuador und er begann diese Politik
umzusetzen um sicherzustellen dass die
Gewinne aus dem Öl den Menschen zugute
kommen nun das gefiel uns in den
Vereinigten Staaten nicht ich wurde als
einer von mehreren wirtschaftskillern
geschickt um Rollos zu korrumpieren ihn
umzust Immen in wissen zu lassen okay
sie können sehr reich werden Sie und
Ihre Familie wenn Sie unser Spiel
mitspielen aber wenn sie weiterhin
versuchen diese Politik die sie
versprochen haben umzusetzen dann werden
sie gehen er wollte nicht hören er wurde
ermordet
sobald das Flugzeug abgestürzt war wurde
das gesamte Gebiet abgeregelt die
einzigen Menschen die hineingelassen
wurden waren US-Militärs von einem
nahegelegenen Stützpunkt und einige
äquatorianischer Militärs als eine
Untersuchung eingeleitet wurde starben
zwei der hauptzollen bei Autounfällen
bevor sie die Chance hatten auszusagen
im Zusammenhang mit der Ermordung von
heimerodos gab es eine Menge sehr sehr
seltsame Dinge wie die meisten Menschen
die sich mit diesem Fall befasst haben
aber auch ich keine Zweifel daran dass
es sich um ein Attentat handelte und
natürlich habe ich in meiner Position
als wirtschaftskiller immer damit
gerechnet das war immer etwas zustoßen
würde weil er sich nicht korrumpieren
ließ er würde sich nicht so korrumpieren
lassen wie wir das wollten
[Musik]
der Präsident von Panama war einer
meiner Lieblingsmenschen ich mochte ihn
sehr sehr gerne er war sehr
charismatisch er war ein Mann der seinem
Land wirklich helfen wollte als ich
versuchte ihn zu bestechen oder zu
korrumpieren sagte er sie mal John er
nannte mich Juanito er sagte hör zu
Juanito ich brauche das Geld nicht was
ich wirklich brauche ist dass mein Land
fair behandelt wird ich möchte dass die
USA die Schulden zurückzahlen die sie
meinem Volk für all die Zerstörung
Schulden die sie hier angerichtet haben
ich muss in der Lage sein anderen
lateinamerikanischen Ländern dabei zu
helfen ihre Unabhängigkeit zu erlangen
und sich von dieser schrecklichen
Präsenz aus dem Norden zu befreien mit
der Sie uns so sehr Ausbeuten ich möchte
dass der Panama Kanal wieder in die
Hände des panamaischen Volkes kommt das
ist es was ich will also lasst mich in
Ruhe versucht nicht mich zu bestechen es
war 1981 und im Mai wurde das ermordet
und egal was ich dessen sehr bewusst
turrikos versammelte seine Familie und
sagte ich bin wahrscheinlich der nächste
aber das ist okay denn ich habe getan
wozu ich hergekommen bin ich habe den
Kanal neu ausgehandelt der Kanal wird
jetzt in unseren Händen sein er hatte
gerade die Vertragsverhandlungen mit
Jimmy Carter abgeschlossen im Juni
desselben Jahres nur ein paar Monate
später starb auch er bei einem
Flugzeugabsturz der zweifellos von CIA
Leuten herbeigeführt wurde es gab eine
enorme Menge an Beweisen einer von
Tourismus Sicherheitsleuten gab ihm im
letzten Moment als er das Flugzeug
besteht ein kleines Tonbandgerät das
eine Bombe enthielt
[Musik]
ich finde es interessant dass dieses
System seit Jahren immer wieder auf die
gleiche Weise abläuft nur dass die
wirtschaftskiller besser und besser und
besser geworden sind wir haben gesehen
was in Venezuela passiert ist im Jahr
1988 wurde Hugo Chavez zum Präsidenten
gewählt nach einer langen Reihe von
Präsidenten die sehr korrupt waren und
im Grunde die Wirtschaft des Landes
zerstört haben und Travis wurde inmitten
all dieser Ereignisse gewählt Jarvis
stellte sich den Vereinigten Staaten
entgegen und forderte vor allem dass das
venezolanische Öl zu Unterstützung des
Volkes verwendet werden sollte nun das
gefiel uns in den Vereinigten Staaten
nicht also wurde 2002 ein Staatsstreich
inszeniert und für mich und die meisten
anderen steht außer Frage dass die CIA
dahinter steckte die Art und Weise wie
dieser Putsch angezettelt wurde
erinnerte stark an das was mit Rose Welt
im Iran getan hatte
im Iran getan hatte nämlich könnte dafür
zu bezahlen auf die Straße zu gehen zu
randalieren zu protestieren und zu sagen
dass dieser chavis sehr unbeliebt ist
wenn man ein paar tausend Menschen dazu
bringen kann kann das Fernsehen es so
aussehen lassen als ob es das ganze Land
wäre und die Dinge beginnen sich zu
entwickeln aber chave ist war klug genug
und das Volk stand so stark hinter ihm
dass er die Situation überwandt was ein
phänomenaler Moment in der Geschichte
Lateinamerikas war
der Irak ist eigentlich ein perfektes
Beispiel dafür wie das ganze System
funktioniert wir wirtschaftskiller sind
die erste Verteidigungslinie wir gehen
rein versuchen Regierungen zu
korrumpieren und sie dazu zu bringen
riesige Kredite zu akzeptieren die dir
dann als Druckmittel benutzen um sie im
Grunde zu besitzen wenn wir scheitern
dann ist die zweite Verteidigungslinie
dass wir Schakale schicken und die
Schakale stürzen entweder die
Regierungen oder sie ermorden sie und
wenn das passiert und eine neue
Regierung ins Land kommt dann wird sie
sich an die Regeln halten weil der neue
Präsident weiß was passiert wenn er es
nicht tut im Falle des Irak ist beides
viel geschlagen die wirtschaftskiller
waren nicht in der Lage zu Saddam
Hussein durchzudringen wir versuchten
ihn dazu zu bringen ein Abkommen zu
akzeptieren aber er wollte nicht und so
gingen die Schakale hin um ihn zu
beseitigen aber sie konnten nicht die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen waren sehr gut
immerhin hatte er mal für die CIA
gearbeitet er war beauftragt worden
einen ehemaligen irakischen Präsidenten
zu ermorden und scheiterte aber er
kannte das System im Jahr 91 schickten
wir also die Truppen und schalteten das
irakische Militär aus wir gingen davon
aus dass Hussein zur Vernunft kommen
würde natürlich hätten wir ihnen damals
schon ausschalten können aber wir
wollten nicht er ist die Art von starker
Mann die wir mögen er hat sein Volk
unter Kontrolle wir dachten er könnte
die Kurden kontrollieren und die Iraner
an ihrer Grenze halten und weiter Öl für
uns Punkten und dass er nachdem wir sein
Militär ausgeschaltet haben wieder zu
Vernunft kommen würde also gingen die
wirtschaftskiller in den 90er Jahren
zurück ohne Erfolg hätten sie Erfolg
gehabt würde er immer noch das Land
regieren wir würden ihm all die
Kampfflugzeuge verkaufen die er will und
alles andere aber sie konnten es nicht
also schickten wir wieder das Militär
und diesmal erledigten wir den ganzen
Job und schalteten ihn aus und
verschafften uns dabei einige sehr
lukrative Bauaufträge wir mussten ein
Land wieder aufbauen dass wir im
Wesentlichen zerstört hatten was ein
ziemlich gutes Geschäft ist wenn man
große Baufirmen besetzt
der Fall des Irak zeigt also die drei
Stufen die wirtschaftskiller versagen
die Schakale versagen und als letzte
Maßnahme greift das Militär ein
auf diese Weise haben wir ein Imperium
geschaffen aber wir haben es sehr subtil
gemacht es passiert im Verborgenen alle
Imperien der Vergangenheit wurden auf
dem Militär aufgebaut und jeder wusste
das die Briten wussten dass sie sie
Aufbauten die Franzosen die Deutschen
die Römer die Griechen und sie waren
stolz darauf sie hatten immer irgendeine
Ausrede wie die Zivilisierung die
Verbreitung irgendeiner Religion oder
etwas ähnliches aber sie wussten dass
sie es taten wir wissen es nicht die
Mehrheit der Menschen in den Vereinigten
Staaten hat keine Ahnung dass wir von
den Vorteilen eines heimlichen Imperiums
leben das ist heute mehr Sklaverei auf
der Welt gibt als je zuvor und dann muss
man sich fragen na ja wenn es einem
Imperium ist wer ist dann der Herrscher
offensichtlich sind unsere
US-Präsidenten keine Herrscher ein
Herrscher ist jemand der nicht gewählt
wird keine begrenzte Amtszeit hat und im
Grunde niemandem unterstellt ist man
kann unsere Präsidenten also nicht auf
diese Weise klassifizieren aber wir
haben etwas dass ich für Äquivalent des
Herrschers halte ich nenne es die
korporatokratie
die korporadokratie ist diese Gruppe von
Individuen die unsere größten
Unternehmen leiten sie handeln wirklich
wie Herrscher sie kontrollieren unsere
Medien entweder durch direkten Besitz
oder durch Werbung sie kontrollieren die
meisten unserer Politiker weil sie ihre
Kampagnen finanzieren entweder durch
ihre Unternehmen oder durch persönliche
Spenden die von den Unternehmen kommen
sie werden nicht gewählt sie haben keine
begrenzte Amtszeit sie sind niemandem
Rechenschaft schuldig und an der Spitze
der korporatokratie kann man wirklich
nicht sagen ob eine Person für einen
privates Unternehmen oder die Regierung
arbeitet weil sie ständig hin und her
wechseln in einem Moment ist jemand
Präsident einer großen Baufirma wie
Halliburton im nächsten Moment ist der
Vizepräsident der Vereinigten Staaten
oder der Präsident ist im Ölgeschäft
tätig und das gilt unabhängig davon ob
Demokraten oder Republikaner im Amt sind
sie bewegen sich durch die Drehtür hin
und her in gewisser Weise ist unsere
Regierung die meiste Zeit unsichtbar und
ihre Politik wird auf der einen oder
anderen Ebene von unseren Konzernen
ausgeführt und dann wiederum wird die
Politik der Regierung im Grunde von den
Konzernen geschmiedet und dann der
Regierung vorgelegt und sie wird zu
Regierungspolitik es ist eine
unglaublich vertraute Beziehung es
handelt sich hier nicht um eine
Verschwörungstheorie diese Leute müssen
sich nicht zusammen tun und verschwören
um etwas zu tun sie arbeiten alle unter
einer einzigen Grundannahme nämlich dass
sie ihre Gewinne maximieren müssen ohne
Rücksicht auf die sozialen und
ökologischen Kosten
dieser Prozess der Manipulation durch
die kooperatokratie mittels Schulden
Bestechung und politischem Umsturz wird
Globalisierung genannt
genauso wie die Federal Reserve die
amerikanische Öffentlichkeit durch
ständige Schulden Inflation und Zinsen
in einer Position der Schuldknechtschaft
hält erfüllen die Weltbank und der IWF
diese Aufgabe auf globaler Ebene der
grundlegende Betrug ist einfach man
verschuldet ein Land entweder durch
seine eigene Indiskretion oder durch die
Korrumpierung des Führers dieses Landes
und er legt dann Konditionen oder
Strukturanpassungsmaßnahmen auf die oft
aus folgendem bestehen
Abwertung der Währung wenn der Wert
einer Währung sinkt sind auch alles was
in dieser Währung bewertet wird dadurch
werden die Einheimischen Ressourcen für
raubtierländer zu einem Bruchteil ihres
Wertes verfügbar
Starter Mittelkürzungen für
Sozialprogramme dazu gehören in der
Regel das Bildungs- und das
Gesundheitswesen was das Wohlergehen und
die Integrität der Gesellschaft
gefährdet und die Bevölkerung anfällig
für Ausbeutung macht Privatisierung von
Staatsbetrieben dies bedeutet das
gesellschaftlich wichtige Systeme von
ausländischen Konzernen aufgekauft und
reguliert werden können um Profit zu
machen so bestand die Weltbank 1999
darauf dass die bolivianische Regierung
das öffentliche Wasserversorgungssystem
ihrer drittgrößten Stadt an eine
Tochterunternehmen des US-Konzerns
spectil verkauft sobald dies geschah
stiegen die Wasserrechnungen für die
ohnehin schon verarmten Einwohner der
Stadt in die Höhe erst nach einem großen
Aufstand der Bevölkerung wurde der
Wechsel Vertrag gekippt
dann gibt es noch die
Handelsliberalisierung also die Öffnung
der Wirtschaft durch die Aufhebung aller
Beschränkungen für den Außenhandel dies
ermöglicht eine Reihe missbräuchlicher
wirtschaftlicher Eingriffe zum Beispiel
durch transnationale Konzerne die ihre
eigenen Massenprodukte einführen die
einheimische Produktion unterbieten und
die lokale Wirtschaft ruinieren ein
Beispiel dafür ist Jamaika das nach der
Annahme von Krediten und Auflagen der
Weltbank seine größten Märkte für
Nutzpflanzen durch den Wettbewerb mit
westlichen Importen verloren
heute sind zahllose Bauern arbeitslos
weil sie nicht mit den großen Konzernen
konkurrieren können
eine andere Variante ist die Entstehung
zahlreicher scheinbar unbemerkter
unregulierter unmenschlicher
sweatshop-fabriken die die aufgezwungene
wirtschaftliche Notlage ausnutzen
darüber hinaus führt die diregulierung
der Produktion zu einer ständigen
Umweltzerstörung da die Ressourcen eines
Landes häufig von gleichgültigen
Unternehmen ausgebeutet werden die
gleichzeitig große Mengen an
absichtlicher Umweltverschmutzung
produzieren
die größte umweltklage der Geschichte
wurde im Namen von 30.000 Menschen aus
Ecuador und dem Amazonasgebiet gegen
texeco eingereicht was heute zu Jerome
gehört es wird geschätzt dass der
Öltanker Exon Valdis mehr als 18 mal die
Küste Alaskas verschmutzt hat im Falle
von Ecuador war das kein Unfall die
Ölgesellschaften haben es absichtlich
getan sie taten es um Geld zu sparen
anstatt für eine ordnungsgemäße
Entsorgung zu bezahlen
ein flüchtiger Blick auf die
Leistungsbilanz der Weltbank zeigt dass
die Institution die öffentlich behauptet
armen Ländern zu helfen und die Armut zu
lindern nichts anderes Tat als die Armut
und das Wohlstandsgefälle zu vergrößern
während die Unternehmensgewinne in die
Höhe schnellen
1960 betrug das Einkommensgefälle
zwischen dem Fünftel der Bevölkerung in
den reichsten Ländern und dem Fünftel in
den ärmsten Ländern 30 zu 1
1998 lag es bei 74:1
während des weltweite BSP zwischen 1970
und 85 und 40% stieg nahm die Zahl der
in Armut lebenden Menschen um 17% zu
zwischen 1985 und 2000 stieg die Zahl
derjenigen die mit weniger als einem
Dollar pro Tag auskommen müssen um 18%
. selbst der gemeinsame
Wirtschaftsausschuss des US-Kongresses
gab zu dass die Erfolgsquote aller
weltbankprojekte bei nur 40% liegt
in den späten 60er Jahren intervenierte
die Weltbank in Ecuador mit
umfangreichen Krediten in den folgenden
30 Jahren stieg die Armut von 50 auf
70%, die Arbeitslosigkeit stieg von 15
auf
70%, die Staatsverschuldung von 240
Millionen auf 16 Milliarden Dollar
während der Anteil der für die Armen
bereitgestellten Mittel von 20 auf 6%
Sankt
im Jahr 2000 mussten sogar 50 Prozent
des äquatorianischen Staatshaushaltes
für die Begleichung der Schulden
aufgewendet werden
es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass die
Weltbank in Wirklichkeit eine US-Bank
ist die US-Interessen unterstützt denn
die Vereinigten Staaten haben ein
Vetorecht bei Entscheidungen da sie der
größte Kapitalgeber sind und woher hat
sie dieses Geld sie haben es durch das
System der mindestreservebanken aus dem
Nichts geschaffen
von den 100 größten Volkswirtschaften
der Welt gemessen am jährlichen
Bruttoinlandsprodukt sind 51 Konzerne
und 57 dieser 51 sind in den USA
ansässig Walmart General Motors und Exon
sind wirtschaftlich mächtiger als
Saudi-Arabien Polen Norwegen Südafrika
Finnland Indonesien und viele andere
[Musik]
Märkten manipuliert und staatliche
Wirtschaftssysteme zugunsten von offenem
Wettbewerb und globalen Kapitalismus
umgestoßen werden
expandiert das Imperium
ihr Start auf euren kleinen 21 Zoll
Bildschirm und heult über Amerika und
Demokratie es gibt keine Demokratie
es gibt nur IBM und
it-dao Julian
das sind die Nationen der Welt von heute
was glauben Sie worüber die Russen in
ihrem staatsräten sprechen Karl Marx sie
holen Ihre linearen programmiertabellen
statistischen entscheidungstheorien und
Minimax Lösungen hervor und berechnen
die preiskosten Wahrscheinlichkeiten
ihre Transaktionen und Investitionen
genau wie wir es tun
wir leben nicht mehr in einer Welt der
Nationen und Ideologien mr Bean die Welt
ist ein Kollegium von Unternehmen das
unerbittlich von den unveränderlichen
Statuten der Wirtschaft bestimmt wird
die Welt ist ein Geschäft Mister Biel
die Welt wird von einer Handvoll
Wirtschaftsmächten übernommen die die
natürlichen Ressourcen die wir zum Leben
brauchen beherrschen und gleichzeitig
das Geld kontrollieren dass wir brauchen
um diese Ressourcen zu erhalten das
Endergebnis wird ein weltmonopol sein
das nicht auf menschlichem Leben sondern
auch finanzieller und unternehmerischer
macht passiert
und da die Ungleichheit wächst
verzweifeln immer mehr Menschen
also war das es Tablet gezwungen sich
einen neuen Weg auszudenken um mit jedem
umzugehen der das System in Frage stellt
so wurde der Terrorist geboren
der Begriff Terrorist ist eine leere
Bezeichnung für jede Person oder Gruppe
die das Establishment herausfordern will
er ist nicht zu verwechseln mit der
fiktiven al-Qaida die eigentlich der
Name einer computerdatenbank für die von
den USA unterstützten Mutter hydinen in
den 80er Jahren war
[Musik]
im Jahr 2007 erhielt das
Verteidigungsministerium
161,8 Milliarden Dollar für den
sogenannten globalen Krieg gegen den
Terrorismus nach Angaben des National
Counter terrison Center wurden im Jahr
2004 international etwa 2000 Menschen
durch vermeintliche Terroranschläge
getötet von dieser Zahl waren 70
Amerikaner liegt man diese Zahl als
allgemeinen Durchschnitt zugrunde was
äußerst großzügig ist so ist es
interessant festzustellen dass pro Jahr
doppelt so viele Menschen an Erdnuss
Allergien sterben wie ein
Terroranschlägen
die Haupt Todesursache in den USA ist
die koronare Herzkrankheit
an der jedes Jahr etwa 450.000 Menschen
sterben im Jahr 2007 stellte die
Regierung etwa 3 Milliarden Dollar für
die Forschung in diesem Bereich zur
Verfügung das bedeutet dass die
US-Regierung im Jahr 2007 54 mal so viel
für die terrorismusprävention ausgab wie
für die Prävention einer Krankheit die
jährlich 6.600 mal mehr Menschen tötet
als der Terrorismus
da jedoch die Worte Terrorismus und
Al-Qaida willkürlich auf jeden
Nachrichten Bericht über jede gegen
US-Interessen gerichtete Aktionen
aufgestempelt werden wird der Mythos
immer größer Mitte 2008 schlug der
US-Justizminister sogar vor dem
US-Kongress offiziell den Krieg gegen
die Fantasie zu erklären
ganz zu schweigen davon dass seit Juli
2008 über eine Million Menschen auf der
us-terrorliste stehen
diese sogenannten Anti-Terror-Maßnahmen
haben natürlich nichts mehr sozialem
Schutz zu tun sondern mit der
Aufrechterhaltung des ist publishmens
inmitten der wachsenden
des Unternehmens Imperiums stützt dass
die Welt ausbeutet
die waren Terroristen unserer Welt
treffen sich nicht um Mitternacht an den
dogs oder schreien aller Akbar bevor Sie
eine gewalttätige Aktion starten
die waren Terroristen unserer Welt
tragen 5000 Dollar Anzüge und arbeiten
in den höchsten Positionen von Finanzen
Regierung und Wirtschaft
was können wir also tun wir können wir
ein System der Gier und Korruption
stoppen das so viel Macht und Schwung
hat wie stoppen wir dieses abartige
Gruppenverhalten das kein Mitgefühl
empfindet für die Millionen die im Irak
und in Afghanistan abgeschlachtet wurden
damit die kooperatokratie die
Energieressourcen und die
Opiumproduktion für den Profit der Wall
Street kontrollieren kann
vor 1980 produzierte Afghanistan 0% des
weltweiten Opiums nachdem die von den
USA und der CIA unterstützten Mutter
hebiden den sowjetischer afghanischen
Krieg gewannen produzierte das Land 1986
40% des weltweiten heroints bis 1999
produzierten sie 80% des gesamten
Marktangebots doch dann geschah etwas
Unerwartetes die Taliban kamen an die
Macht und zerstörten die meisten
Opiumfelder die Produktion Sankt von
3000 auf 155 Tonnen am 9 September 2001
lagen die Invasionspläne für Afghanistan
Präsident Busch vor zwei Tage später
hatten sie ihre Ausrede
heute bricht die Opiumproduktion in dem
von den USA kontrollierten Afghanistan
fast jedes Jahr neue Rekorde
wie stoppen wir ein System der Gier und
Korruption das arme
Bevölkerungsschichten zum Nutzen der
Madison Avenue zu Ausbeuter Sklaverei
verurteilt das Terroranschläge unter
falscher Flagge zum Zwecke der
Manipulation einsetzt
das soziale Funktionsweisen schafft die
von Natur aus ausbeuterisch sind
oder das systematisch die bürgerlichen
Freiheiten einschränkt und die
Menschenrechte verletzt um sich vor
seinen eigenen Unzulänglichkeiten zu
schützen
wie gehen wir mit den zahlreichen
verdeckten Institutionen wie dem Rat für
auswärtige Beziehungen der Trilateralen
Kommission und der bilderberggruppe
sowie anderen undemokratisch gewählten
Gruppen um die hinter verschlossenen
Türen zusammenarbeiten um die
politischen finanziellen sozialen und
ökologischen Elemente unseres Landes zu
kontrollieren um die Antwort zu finden
müssen wir zunächst die wahre Ursache
finden
denn Tatsache ist dass die egoistischen
korrupten macht und profitorientierten
Gruppen nicht die wahre Ursache des
Problems sind
sie sind die Symptome
Gier und Wettbewerb sind nicht das
Ergebnis eines unveränderlichen
menschlichen Temperaments Gier und Angst
vor Knappheit werden tatsächlich erzeugt
und verstärkt die direkte Folge ist dass
wir gegeneinander kämpfen müssen um zu
überleben Bernard leadär
mein Name ist Jack fresco ich bin
Industriedesigner und sozial engineer
ich interessiere mich sehr für die
Gesellschaft und die Entwicklung eines
Systems das für alle Menschen nachhaltig
sein könnte
zunächst einmal ist das Wort Korruption
eine monetäre Erfindung dieses
abweichende Verhalten ein Verhalten dass
das Wohlergehen der Menschen stört hat
mit dem menschlichen Verhalten zu tun
und menschliches Verhalten scheint
umweltbedingt zu sein das heißt wenn sie
als Baby bei den Seminolen Indianern
aufgewachsen wären und nie etwas anderes
gesehen hätten würden sie dieses
Wertesystem übernehmen und das gilt für
Nationen für Einzelpersonen für Familien
sie versuchen ihre Kinder mit ihrem
besonderen Glauben zu indoktrinieren und
ihnen das Gefühl zu geben dass sie dazu
gehören und sie bauen eine Gesellschaft
auf die sie als etabliert bezeichnen sie
legen einen praktikablen Standpunkt fest
und neigen dazu diesen aufrecht zu
erhalten dabei sind alle Gesellschaften
in Wirklichkeit im Entstehen begriffen
und nicht etabliert und so bekämpfen sie
neue Ideen die das establishmen stören
würden
Regierungen versuchen das aufrecht zu
erhalten was sie an der Macht hält die
Menschen werden nicht in ein politisches
Amt gewählt um etwas zu verändern sie
werden gewählter Dinge so bleiben wie
sie sind
sie sehen also die Grundlage der
Korruption liegt in unserer Gesellschaft
lassen Sie mich das klarstellen alle
Nationen sind im Grunde genommen korrupt
weil sie dazu neigen bestehende
Institutionen aufrecht zu erhalten ich
will nicht alle Nationen hoch oder
herabstufen aber Kommunismus Sozialismus
Faschismus das System der freien
Marktwirtschaft und alle anderen
Subkulturen sind dasselbe sie alle sind
im Grunde genommen korrupt
das grundlegendste Merkmal unserer
sozialen Institutionen ist die
Notwendigkeit der Selbsterhaltung egal
ob es sich um ein Unternehmen eine
Religion oder eine Regierung handelt das
oberste Interesse besteht darin die
Institution selbst zu erhalten das
letzte was eine Ölgesellschaft jemals
wollen würde ist die Nutzung von Energie
die sich ihrer Kontrolle entzieht denn
dadurch verliert dieses Unternehmen an
Bedeutung für die Gesellschaft
ebenso waren der Kalte Krieg und der
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion in
Wirklichkeit ein Mittel um die
etablierte wirtschaftliche und globale
Hegemonie der Vereinigten Staaten
aufrecht zu erhalten
in ähnlicher Weise haben die Religionen
die Menschen darauf konditioniert sich
für natürliche Neigungen schuldig zu
fühlen wobei jede von ihnen behauptet
den einzigen Weg zur Vergebung und
Erlösung zu bieten im Zentrum dieser
institutionellen selbst Erhaltung steht
das Geldsystem denn es ist das Geld dass
die Mittel für Macht und Überleben
bereitstellt sowie ein armer Mensch
gezwungen sein könnte zu stehlen um zu
überleben ist es eine natürliche Neigung
alles zu tun was notwendig ist um die
Rentabilität einer Institution aufrecht
zu erhalten das macht das für
profitorientierte Institutionen
naturgemäß schwierig sich zu ändern denn
es gefährdet nicht nur das Überleben
großer Gruppen von Menschen sondern auch
den begehrten materialistischen
Lebensstil der mit Wohlstand und macht
verbunden ist
die lähmenden Notwendigkeit eine
Institution ohne Rücksicht auf ihre
gesellschaftliche Relevanz zu erhalten
ist daher weitgehend auf das Bedürfnis
nach Geld oder Profit zurückzuführen
was mich interessiert ist warum Menschen
denken wenn ein Mann mit dem Verkauf
eines bestimmten Produkts Geld verdient
würde natürlich die Existenz eines
anderen Produkts bekämpfen dass seine
Institution bedrohen könnte
deshalb können die Menschen nicht fair
sein und die Menschen trauen einander
nicht
ein Mann wird zu Ihnen kommen und sagen
ich habe genau das Haus das sie suchen
er ist ein Geschäftsmann wenn ein Arzt
sagt ich glaube ihre Niere muss raus
weiß ich nicht ob er versucht eine Yacht
zu bezahlen oder ob meine Niere
tatsächlich raus muss in einem
Geldsystem ist es schwer Menschen zu
vertrauen wenn sie in meinen Laden kämen
und ich würde sagen diese Lampe die ich
habe es ziemlich gut aber die Lampe
neben alles viel besser dann würde ich
nicht lange im Geschäft bleiben es würde
nicht funktionieren wenn ich ethisch
handeln würde würde es nicht
funktionieren wenn Sie also sagen die
Industrie kümmere sich um die Menschen
das stimmt nicht sie kann es sich nicht
leisten ethisch zu sein Ihr System ist
also nicht darauf ausgelegt dem Wohl der
Menschen zu dienen es gäbe keine
Auslagerung von Arbeitsplätzen wenn sie
sich um die Menschen kümmern würde die
Industrie kümmert sich nicht sie stellt
nur Leute ein weil es noch nicht
automatisiert wurde also reden sie nicht
von Anstand und Ethik wir können uns das
nicht leisten und gleichzeitig im
Geschäft bleiben
es ist wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass
unabhängig vom Gesellschaftssystem
opferistisch sozialistisch
kapitalistisch oder kommunistisch der
zugrunde liegende Mechanismus immer noch
Geld Arbeit und Wettbewerb ist das
kommunistische China ist nicht weniger
kapitalistisch als die Vereinigten
Staaten der einzige Unterschied ist das
Ausmaß in dem der Staat in die
Unternehmen eingreift die Realität ist
dass der Monetarismus sozusagen der
wahre Mechanismus ist der die Interessen
aller Länder der Erde leitet die
aggressivste und daher dominierende
Variante dieses Monetarismus ist das
System der freien Marktwirtschaft
die grundlegende Perspektive wie sie von
frühen Ökonomen der freien
Marktwirtschaft wie Adam Smith dargelegt
wurde ist das Eigeninteresse und
Wettbewerb zu sozialem Wohlstand führen
da der Akt des Wettbewerbs Anreize
schafft die die Menschen motivieren
durchzuhalten
worüber jedoch nicht gesprochen wird ist
die Tatsache dass eine auf Wettbewerb
basierende Wirtschaft unweigerlich zu
strategischer Korruption macht und
Vermögens Konsolidierung sozialer
Schichtenbildung technologischer Lähmung
arbeitsmissbrauch und letztlich zu einer
verdeckten Form der regierungsdiktatur
durch die reiche Elite führt
das Wort Korruption wird oft als
moralische Perversion definiert wenn ein
Unternehmen Giftmüll in den Ozean kippt
um Geld zu sparen erkennen die meisten
Menschen die es als korruptes Verhalten
an
auf einer subtileren Ebene wenn Walmart
in eine Kleinstadt sieht und kleine
Geschäfte zu Schließung zwingt weil sie
nicht konkurrenzfähig sind entsteht eine
Grauzone denn was genau macht Walmart
falsch warum sollten sie sich um die
kleinen Unternehmen kümmern die sie
zerstören
noch subtiler ist es wenn jemand
entlassen wird weil eine neue Maschine
entwickelt wurde die die Arbeit für
weniger Geld erledigen kann
dann neigen die Menschen dazu dass
einfach so hinzunehmen ohne die
Unmenschlichkeit einer solchen Handlung
zu erkennen
denn egal ob es sich um die Entsorgung
von Giftmüll einen Monopol Unternehmen
oder den Abbau von Arbeitsplätzen
handelt das Motiv ist dasselbe Profit
sie alle sind unterschiedliche
Ausprägungen desselben selbst
erhaltungsmechanismus der das
Wohlergehen der Menschen stets über den
finanziellen Gewinn stellt
daher ist Korruption nicht irgendein
Nebenprodukt des Monetarismus
und obwohl die meisten Menschen diese
Tendenz auf der einen oder anderen Ebene
anerkennen bleibt die Mehrheit naiv was
die weitreichenden Auswirkungen eines
solchen egoistischen Mechanismus als
leitmentalität in der Gesellschaft
betrifft
interne Dokumente zeigen dass dieses
Unternehmen nachdem es mit Sicherheit
wusste dass es ein Medikament hatte das
mit dem Aids-Virus verunreinigt war das
Produkt in den USA vom magnamen und es
in Europa Asien und Lateinamerika
verkaufte die US-Regierung ließ das zu
die FDA liest das zu und jetzt schaut
die Regierung einfach weg tausende
unschuldiger blutkranker sind an dem
Aids-Virus gestorben dieses Unternehmen
wusste genau dass das Mittel verseucht
war sie haben es weiterverkauft weil sie
aus diesem Desaster Profit schlagen
wollten
sie sehen also sie haben eine eingebaute
Korruption wir beklauen uns alle
gegenseitig bei so etwas kann man keinen
Anstand erwarten
und wenn Sie das Spüren wissen sie nicht
wen sie wählen sollen sie denken in
Begriffen der Demokratie was in einer
geldbasierten Wirtschaft nicht möglich
ist
wenn man mehr Geld hat um für seine
Position zu werben für die Position die
man in der Regierung anstrebt dann ist
das keine Demokratie es dient denen die
in Positionen mit unterschiedlichen
Vorteilen sind es ist also immer eine
Diktatur der Eliten der finanziell
wohlhabenden
es ist eine interessante Beobachtung wie
scheinbar unbekannte Persönlichkeiten
auf magische Weise als
Präsidentschaftskandidaten auf der
Bildfläche erscheinen und Ehemann sich
versieht hat man die Wahl zwischen einer
kleinen Gruppe extrem wohlhabender Leute
die verdächtigerweise dieselbe weit
gefasste gesellschaftliche Meinung
vertreten
offensichtlich ist das ein Scherz die
Leute die auf dem Wahlzettel stehen
werden gewählt weil sie von den
etablierten finanzmächten die das Sagen
haben für akzeptabel befunden wurden
dennoch denken viele die diese Illusion
von Demokratie haben oft wenn wir nur
unsere ehrlichen ethischen Politiker an
die Macht bringen könnten dann wäre
alles in Ordnung
nun dieser Gedanke erscheint in unserer
etablierten orientierten Weltsicht zwar
vernünftig ist aber leider ein weiterer
Trugschluss
denn wenn es wirklich darauf ankommt was
wirklich wichtig ist haben die
Institution der Politik und damit die
Politiker selbst absolut keine wirkliche
Relevanz für das was unsere Welt und
Gesellschaft funktionieren lässt
es sind nicht die Politiker die Probleme
lösen sie haben keine technischen
Fähigkeiten sie wissen nicht wie man
Probleme löst selbst wenn sie aufrichtig
wären wüssten sie nicht wie man Probleme
löst es sind die Techniker die die
Entsalzungsanlagen bauen es sind die
Techniker die ihnen Strom geben die
Ihnen Kraftfahrzeuge geben die ihr Haus
heizen und im Sommer kühlen es ist die
Technik die die Probleme löst nicht die
Politik die Politik kann keine Probleme
lösen weil sie dazu nicht ausgebildet
ist
Hirschau nur sehr wenige Menschen halten
heute inne und überlegen was ihr Leben
tatsächlich verbessert ist es Geld
offensichtlich nicht man kann Geld nicht
essen oder Geld in sein Auto stopfen
damit es fährt ist es Politik alles was
Politiker tun können ist Gesetze zu
erlassen Haushalte aufzustellen und
Kriege zu erklären
ist es die Religion natürlich nicht
Religion schafft nichts außer
immateriellem emotionalem Trost für
diejenigen die ihn brauchen das wahre
geschenkt dass wir als Menschen haben
und das allein für alles verantwortlich
ist was unser Leben verbessert hat
ist die Technologie
was ist Technologie Technologie ist ein
Bleistift mit dem man Ideen zu
Kommunikationszwecken auf Papier
festhalten kann Technologie ist ein Auto
mit dem man schneller reisen kann als es
die Füße erlauben Technologie ist eine
Brille die denjenigen die sie brauchen
das Sehen ermöglicht
angewandte Technologie selbst ist
lediglich eine Erweiterung menschliche
Eigenschaften die die menschliche
Anstrengung reduziert und den Menschen
von einer bestimmten Aufgabe oder einem
Problem befreit stellen Sie sich vor wie
ihr Leben heute ohne ein Telefon einen
Ofen einen Computer oder einen Flugzeug
aussehen würde alles was Sie zu Hause
als selbstverständlich ansehen von der
Türklingel über den Tisch bis zum
Geschirrspüler ist Technologie die durch
den kreativen wissenschaftlichen
Einfallsreichtum menschlicher Techniker
entstanden ist
nicht Geld Politik oder Religion
das sind falsche Institutionen
einen Kongressabgeordneten zu schreiben
ist fantastisch man sagt man soll seinem
Abgeordneten schreiben wenn man etwas
erreichen will die Männer in Washington
sollten an der vordersten Front der
Technologie stehen an der vordersten
Front der Geisteswissenschaften der
Kriminalitätsbekämpfung all der Faktoren
die das menschliche Verhalten
beeinflussen sie brauchen ihrem
Kongressabgeordneten nicht zu schreiben
was sind das für Leute die mit dieser
Aufgabe betraut werden die Zukunft wird
sehr schwierig sein die Frage die von
Politikern aufgeworfen wird ist wie viel
kostet ein Projekt aber die Frage ist
nicht wie viel wird es kosten es geht
darum ob wir die Ressourcen haben und
wir haben die Ressourcen um alle
Menschen unterzubringen Krankenhäuser in
der ganzen Welt zu bauen Schulen in der
ganzen Welt zu errichten die besten
Geräte und Labors für die Lehre und die
medizinische Forschung zu bauen sie
sehen also wir haben all das aber wir
befinden uns in einem Geldsystem und in
einem monetären System geht es um Profit
und was ist der grundlegende Mechanismus
der das Gewinnsystem neben dem
Eigeninteresse antreibt was genau ist es
dass diesen Wettbewerbsvorteil im Kern
aufrecht erhält sind es hohe Effizienz
und Nachhaltigkeit nein das ist nicht
Teil ihres Designs nichts was in unserer
gewinnorientierten Gesellschaft
produziert wird ist auch nur annähernd
nachhaltig oder effizient wenn es so
wäre gäbe es keine Millionen schwere
Service Industrie für Automobile auch
würde die durchschnittliche Lebensdauer
der meisten elektronischen Geräte
weniger als drei Monate betragen bevor
sie veraltet sind ist es Überfluss ganz
und gar nicht Überfluss der auf den
Gesetzen von Angebot und Nachfrage
beruht ist eigentlich eine negative
Sache wenn ein Diamanten Unternehmen
beim Abbau zehnmal so viele Diamanten
wie üblich findet bedeutet das dass das
Angebot an Diamanten gestiegen ist was
wiederum bedeutet dass die Kosten und
der Gewinn pro Diamant sinken tatsache
ist das Effizienz Nachhalt igkeit und
Überfluss die Feinde des Profit sind um
es mit einem Wort zu sagen es ist der
Mechanismus der Knappheit der die
Gewinne steigert
was ist Knappheit es geht darum Produkte
wertvoll zu halten wenn man die
Ölproduktion drosselt steigt der Preis
die Beibehaltung der Knappheit von
Diamanten hält den Preis hoch in den
kimberlay-diamanten Minen werden
Diamanten verbrannt um den Preis
hochzuhalten was bedeutet es also für
die Gesellschaft wenn Knappheit entweder
natürlich oder durch Manipulation
erzeugt eine günstige Bedingung für die
Industrie ist
es bedeutet dass Nachhaltigkeit und
Überfluss in einem profitsystem niemals
vorkommen werden weil es einfach der
Natur der Struktur widerspricht
daher ist es unmöglich eine Welt ohne
Krieg und Armut zu haben
es ist unmöglich die Technologie
kontinuierlich bis zu ihrem
effizientesten und produktivsten stand
voranzutreiben und was am dramatischsten
ist es ist unmöglich von den Menschen zu
erwarten dass sie sich wirklich ethisch
oder anständig verhalten
die Menschen benutzen das Wort Instinkt
weil sie sich das Verhalten nicht
erklären können sie lehnen sich zurück
und bewerten mit ihrem mangelnden wissen
und sagen Dinge wie Menschen sind auf
eine bestimmte Art und Weise gebaut gier
ist etwas Natürliches
als ob sie jahrelang daran gearbeitet
hätten und es nicht weniger natürlich
wäre als das Tragen von Kleidung
was wir tun wollen ist die Ursachen der
Probleme zu beseitigen die Prozesse zu
beseitigen die Gier und Scheinheiligkeit
und Vorurteile und gegenseitige
Ausbeutung und Elite denken
hervorbringen
die Notwendigkeit von Gefängnissen und
Sozialhilfe zu beseitigen
wir haben diese Probleme immer gehabt
weil wir immer in einem System der
Knappheit und das Geld ist gelebt haben
das Knappheit erzeugt
wenn man die Bedingungen beseitigt die
zu dem führen was man als sozial
anstößiges Verhalten bezeichnet wird es
das nicht mehr geben man sagt ist das
nicht angeboren
nein ist es nicht
es gibt keine menschliche Natur es gibt
menschliches Verhalten und das hat sich
im Laufe der Geschichte immer wieder
geändert und wird nicht mit
Scheinheiligkeit Gier Korruption und
hassgeboren man nimmt das innerhalb der
Gesellschaft auf
Krieg Armut Korruption Hunger Elends
menschliches Leid werden sich in einem
Geldsystem nicht ändern das heißt es
wird kaum eine signifikante Veränderung
geben es bedarf einer Neugestaltung
unserer Kultur unserer Werte und die
muss sich an der Tragfähigkeit der Erde
orientieren und nicht an irgendeiner
menschlichen Meinung oder den
Vorstellungen eines Politikers darüber
wie die Welt sein sollte oder an
religiösen Vorstellungen über
menschliches Verhalten
und genau darum geht es im venusprojekt
die Gesellschaft über die wir jetzt
sprechen ist eine Gesellschaft die frei
ist von all dem alten Aberglauben von
einkerung Gefängnissen Polizei
Grausamkeit und Gesetz
alle Gesetze werden verschwinden und
auch die Berufe die keine Berechtigung
mehr haben
Börsen
für immer weil sie nicht mehr relevant
sind
wenn wir verstehen dass es die von
menschlichem Einfallsreichtum er dachte
Technologie ist die die Menschen befreit
und unsere Lebensqualität steigert dann
erkennen wir dass der wichtigste Fokus
den wir haben können auf dem
intelligenten Umgang mit den Ressourcen
der Welt liegt denn aus diesen
natürlichen Ressourcen gewinnen wir die
Materialien um unseren Weg des
Wohlstands vorzusetzen wenn wir das
verstehen erkennen wir das Geld im
Grunde ein Hindernis für diese
Ressourcen darstellt
denn praktisch alles hat einen
finanziellen Preis und warum brauchen
wir Geld um diese Ressourcen zu erhalten
wegen der tatsächlichen oder
angenommenen Knappheit
für Luft und Leitungswasser zahlen wir
normalerweise nicht weil es im Überfluss
vorhanden ist und es sinnlos wäre es zu
verkaufen
wenn also logischerweise Ressourcen und
Technologien mit denen alles in unserer
Gesellschaft geschaffen wird die Häuser
Städte und Verkehrsmittel in
ausreichendem Maße vorhanden wären gäbe
es keinen Grund etwas zu verkaufen
ebenso gäbe es keinen Grund Arbeit zu
haben wenn Automatisierung und Maschinen
so weit fortgeschritten wären dass sie
den Menschen die Arbeit abnehmen würden
und wenn diese sozialen Aspekte erledigt
werden gäbe es keinen Grund mehr
überhaupt Geld zu haben die letzte Frage
bleibt also bestehen verfügen wir auf
der Erde über genügend Ressourcen und
technologisches Verständnis um eine
Gesellschaft zu schaffen die so
reichhaltig ist dass alles was wir jetzt
haben ohne Preisschild und ohne die
Notwendigkeit der Unterwerfung durch
Arbeit verfügbar sein könnte
ja das haben wir wir haben die
Ressourcen und die Technologie um dies
zumindest zu ermöglichen zusammen mit
der Fähigkeit den Lebensstandard so hoch
anzuheben dass die Menschen in der
Zukunft auf unsere heutige Zivilisation
zurückblicken und darüber staunen werden
wie primitiv und unreif und unsere
Gesellschaft war
das minusprojekt vorschlägt ist ein
völlig anderes System das dem heutigen
Wissensstand angepasst ist
wir haben die Wissenschaft nie vor die
Frage gestellt wie man eine Gesellschaft
entwirft die langweilige und eintönige
Jobs eliminiert die Unfälle im
Transportwesen eliminiert die den
Menschen einen hohen Lebensstandard
ermöglicht die Gifte in unserer Natur
eliminiert die uns andere Energiequellen
gibt die sauber und effizient sind das
können wir da draußen tun
der Hauptunterschied zwischen einer
Ressourcen basierten Wirtschaft und eine
monetären System besteht darin dass es
in einer ressourcenbasierten Wirtschaft
wirklich um die Menschen und ihr
Wohlergehen geht während ein monetäres
System so verzerrt ist dass die Belange
der Menschen wirklich zweitrangig sind
wenn sie überhaupt vorhanden sind die
Produkte die hergestellt werden sind
darauf ausgerichtet wie viel Geld man
bekommen kann wenn es ein Problem in der
Gesellschaft gibt und man mit der Lösung
dieses Problems kein Geld verdienen kann
dann wird es nicht gelöst die
ressourcenbasierte Wirtschaft ist
wirklich nicht annähernd das was bisher
versucht wurde und mit unserer heutigen
Technologie können wir einen Überfluss
schaffen er könnte dazu genutzt werden
den Lebensstil eines jeden zu verbessern
Überfluss auf der ganzen Welt wenn wir
unsere Technologie klug einsetzen und
die Umwelt erhalten
es ist ein ganz anderes System und es
ist sehr schwer darüber zu sprechen weil
die Öffentlichkeit nicht gut genug über
den Stand der Technik informiert ist
gegenwärtig müssen wir keine fossilen
Brennstoffe verbrennen wir müssen nichts
verwenden was die umweltverschmutzen
würde es sind viele Energiequellen
verfügbar
die vom Establishment propagierten
Alternativen Energielösungen wie
Wasserstoff Biomasse und sogar
Kernenergie sind höchst unzureichend
gefährlich und dienen nur dazu die von
der Industrie geschaffene profitstruktur
aufrecht zu erhalten wenn wir über die
Propaganda und die eigennützigen
Lösungen der Energiekonzerne hinwegsehen
finden wir einen scheinbar endlosen
Strom sauberer reichlich vorhandener und
erneuerbarer Energie zur Stromerzeugung
Solar und Wind Energie sind in der
Öffentlichkeit wohl bekannt aber das
wahre Potenzial dieser alternativen
bleibt unausgesprochen
Solarenergie die von der Sonne stammt
ist so reichlich vorhanden dass eine
Stunde Licht zur Mittagszeit mehr
Energie enthält als die gesamte Welt in
einem Jahr verbraucht wenn wir ein
Hundertstel dieser Energie einfangen
könnten bräuchte die Welt kein Öl kein
Gas und nichts anderes mehr
die Frage ist also nicht die
Verfügbarkeit sondern die Technologie um
sie nutzbar zu machen und es gibt heute
viele Technologien die genau das leisten
könnten wenn sie nicht durch die
Notwendigkeit behindert würden mit den
etablierten Energie macht Strukturen um
Marktanteile zu konkurrieren
dann ist da noch die Windenergie die
Windenergie wurde lange Zeit als schwach
und aufgrund ihrer Standortgebundenheit
als unpraktisch angeprangert das ist
einfach nicht wahr das
US-Energieministerium räumte 2007 ein
dass die Windenergie wenn Sie in nur
drei der 50 amerikanischen Bundesstaaten
vollständig genutzt wurde die gesamte
Nation mit Strom versorgen könnte
das noch die eher unbekannten
Energieträger Gezeiten und Wellen
Energie die Gezeitenkraft wird aus denen
Gezeiten Verschiebungen im Meer gewonnen
die Installation von Turbinen die die
Bewegung einfangen erzeugt Energie im
Vereinigten Königreich gibt es dafür 42
Standorte und das heißt dass 34% des
gesamten britischen Energiebedarfs
allein aus der Gezeitenkraft stammen
könnten die Wellenkraft bei der Energie
aus der Oberflächenbewegung des Ozeans
gewonnen wird schätzungen zufolge ein
weltweites Potenzial von bis zu 80.000
Terawattstunden pro Jahr das heißt das
allein auf diese Weise 50% des gesamten
Energiebedarfs der Erde gewonnen werden
könnten
es ist wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass
für die Nutzung von Gezeiten
wellensonnen und Wind Energie im
Gegensatz zu Kohle Öl Gas Biomasse
Wasserstoff und all den anderen
Energieträgern so gut wie keine
vorherige Energie benötigt wird in
Kombination könnten allein diese vier
Energieträger die Welt für immer mit
Energie versorgen wenn sie mit Hilfe von
Technologie effizient genutzt werden
allerdings gibt es noch eine andere Form
der sauberen erneuerbaren Energie die
sie alle übertrifft
geothermische Energie
nutzt die sogenannte Wärmegewinnung die
durch einen einfachen Prozess unter
Verwendung von Wasser große Mengen
sauberer Energie erzeugen kann
2006 wurde in einem m.it-bericht über
geothermische Energie festgestellt dass
derzeit 13.000 zetter Joule an Energie
in der Erde vorhanden sind wobei 2000
zetterschulen mit verbesserter
Technologie leicht angezapft werden
könnten der gesamten Energieverbrauch
aller Länder der beträgt etwa ein halbes
zetterjoule pro Jahr das bedeutet dass
etwa 4000 Jahre planetarischer Energie
allein auf diesem Weg nutzbar gemacht
werden könnten und wenn wir bedenken
dass sich die Wärmeerzeugung der Erde
ständig erneuert ist diese Energie
wirklich grenzenlos und könnte ewig
genutzt werden diese Quellen sind nur
einige der sauberen erneuerbaren
Energien die zur Verfügung stehen und im
Laufe der Zeit werden wir weitere finden
es ist eine großartige Erkenntnis dass
wir Energie in Hülle und Fülle haben
ohne Umweltverschmutzung ohne die
Notwendigkeit einer traditionellen
Speicherung und ohne ein Preisschild
und was ist mit dem Transportwesen wie
vorherrschenden Transportmittel in
unserer Gesellschaft sind das Auto und
das Flugzeug die beide überwiegend
fossile brennstoffverbrauchen um zu
funktionieren im Falle des Autos gibt es
schon seit vielen Jahren die
Batterietechnologie die benötigt wird um
ein Elektroauto anzutreiben das mit
einer Ladung über 200 Meilen pro Stunde
fahren kann
aufgrund von batteriepatienten die von
der Ölindustrie kontrolliert werden was
ihre Verfügbarkeit einschränkt um den
Marktanteil zu halten und aufgrund des
politischen druckseitens der
Energiewirtschaft ist die Zugänglichkeit
und Erschwinglichkeit dieser Technologie
jedoch begrenzt es gibt absolut keinen
Grund außer reinem korrupten Profit
Interesse warum nicht jedes einzelne
Fahrzeug auf der Welt elektrisch und
absolut sauber sein kann ohne das Benzin
benötigt wird was die Flugzeuge betrifft
ist es an der Zeit zu erkennen dass
diese Art des Reisens in effizient
schwerfällig und langsames und viel zu
viel Umweltverschmutzung verursacht
dies ist eine Magnetschwebebahn sie
nutzt Magnete für den Antrieb sie wird
vollständig von einem Magnetfeld
getragen und benötigt weniger als 2% der
Energie die für Flugreisen benötigt wird
die Bahn hat keine Räder so dass ich
nichts abnutzen kann die derzeitige
Höchstgeschwindigkeit von Versionen
dieser Technologie die sie in Japan
eingesetzt werden beträgt 361 Meilen pro
Stunde allerdings ist diese Version der
Technologie schon veraltet eine
Organisation namens e.t.3 die mit dem
Venus Project in Verbindung steht hat
eine röhrenbasierte Magnetschwebebahn
entwickelt die in einer bewegungslosen
reibungsfreien Röhre die über Land oder
unter Wasser verlaufen kann bis zu 4000
Meilen pro Stunde fahren kann stellen
Sie sich vor Sie könnten in einer
ausgedehnten Mittagspause von La nach
New York fahren oder in zwei Stunden von
Washington nach Peking das ist die
Zukunft des kontinentalen und
interkontinentalen Reisens schnell
sauber und mit nur einem Bruchteil des
Energie Verbrauchs den wir heute für
dieselbe Strecke benötigen mit der
Magnetschwebebahn fortschrittlichen
batteriespeichern und geothermischer
Energie gäbe es keinen Grund jemals
wieder fossile Brennstoffe zu benutzen
und wir könnten das jetzt tun wenn wir
nicht durch die lähmende Profit-Struktur
zurückgehalten würden
Amerika neigt zum Faschismus durch seine
vorherrschende Philosophie und Religion
neigt es dazu faschistische Standpunkte
zu vertreten die amerikanische Industrie
ist im wesentlichen eine faschistische
Institution wenn man das nicht versteht
läuft man in dem Moment in dem man die
Stechuhr drückt in eine Diktatur
uns werden Vorstellungen über die
Anständigkeit der Arbeit vermittelt aber
für mich ist das wirklich bezahlt das
Sklaverei
sie werden in dem Glauben erzogen dass
man seinen Lebensunterhalt im Schweiße
seines Angesichts verdienen muss das
hält die Menschen zurück sie befreien
die Menschen von schweißtreibenden sich
wiederholenden Tätigkeiten die sie
unwissend machen man beraubt sie in
unserer Gesellschaft die eine Ressourcen
basierte Wirtschaft ist befreien
Maschinen die Menschen wir können uns
das nicht vorstellen weil wir diese Art
von Welt nie gekannt haben
wenn wir in der Geschichte zurückblicken
sehen wir ein klares Muster wie die
Automatisierung durch Maschinen langsam
die menschliche Arbeit ersetzt vom
Verschwinden des fahrstuhlführers bis
hin zur fast vollständigen
Automatisierung einer Automobilfabrik
tatsache ist dass der Bedarf an
menschlichen Arbeitskräften mit
zunehmender technologischer Entwicklung
kontinuierlich abnimmt das führt zu
einem ernsthaften Konflikt der die
Falschheit des auf Geld basierenden
Arbeitssystems beweist
denn die menschliche Beschäftigung steht
in direkter Konkurrenz zu
technologischen Entwicklung
angesichts des grundsätzlichen Vorrangs
des Profits durch die Industrie werden
daher im Laufe der Zeit immer mehr
Menschen entlassen und durch Maschinen
ersetzt wenn die Industrie Menschen
einsetzt verkürzt sie nicht den
Arbeitstag sondern verkleinert ihn du
verlierst deinen Job man hat also ein
Recht darauf Maschinen zu fürchten in
einer hochtechnologischen Ressourcen
basierten Wirtschaft könnte man
vorsichtiger Weise sagen dass etwa 90%
aller gegenwärtigen Berufe durch
Maschinen ersetzt werden könnten
so dass die Menschen ihr Leben ohne
Knechtschaft leben könnten denn das ist
der Sinn der Technologie und im Laufe
der Zeit mit der Nanotechnologie und
anderen hochentwickelten Formen der
Wissenschaft ist es nicht weit hergeholt
zu sehen wie auch komplexe medizinische
Verfahren von Maschinen durchgeführt
werden könnten und zwar nach dem
gleichen Muster mit viel höheren
Erfolgsquoten als der Mensch heute hat
der Weg ist klar aber unsere
geldbasierte Struktur die Arbeit als
Einkommen voraussetzt blockiert diesen
Fortschritt denn der Mensch braucht
Arbeit um zu überleben die Quintessenz
ist dass dieses System verschwinden muss
sonst werden wir nie frei sein und die
Technologie wird immer gelähmt sein
wir haben Maschinen wie die
Abwasserkanäle reinigen das befreit den
Menschen von dieser Aufgabe betrachten
Sie also Maschinen als Erweiterung der
menschlichen Leistung
darüber hinaus haben viele Berufe in
einer Ressourcen basierten Wirtschaft
einfach keine Existenzgrundlage mehr
zum Beispiel alles was mit der
Verwaltung von Geld Werbung und dem
Rechtssystem zu tun hat
denn ohne Geld würde ein Großteil der
Verbrechen die heute begangen werden nie
geschehen praktisch alle Formen der
Kriminalität sind eine Folge des
Geldsystems
entweder direkt oder durch Neurosen die
durch finanzielle Entbehrungen
hervorgerufen werden
daher könnten die Gesetze selbst
irgendwann aussterben
anstatt ein Schild fahren Sie vorsichtig
oder Vorsicht Rutschgefahr bei Nässe
aufzustellen sollten Sie die Straße mit
einem Mittel bestreuen damit sie bei
Regen nicht rutschig ist und wenn jemand
betrunken in ein Auto steigt und das
Auto stark schwankt gibt es ein kleines
Pendel das auf und abschwingt und das
Auto zur Seite zieht das ist keine
gesetzliche Lösung bauen sie so nah und
Radar in Autos ein damit sie nicht
zusammenstoßen von Menschen geschaffene
Gesetze sind Versuche mit auftretenden
Problemen umzugehen da sie nicht wissen
wie sie sie lösen können machen sie ein
Gesetz in den Vereinigten Staaten den
privatisiertesten kapitalistischsten
Land der Welt sollte es nicht
überraschen dass es auch die größte
gefängnispopulation der Welt hat die
jedes Jahr wächst
statistisch gesehen sind die meisten
dieser Menschen ungebildet und kommen
aus armen benachteiligten Verhältnissen
und entgegen der Propaganda ist es diese
Konditionierung die Sie zu kriminellem
und gewalttätigem Verhalten verleitet
die Gesellschaft sieht in diesem Punkt
jedoch Weg
das rechts und das Gefängnissystem sind
nur weitere Beispiele dafür wie unsere
Gesellschaft es vermeidet die Ursachen
von Verhalten zu untersuchen jedes Jahr
werden Milliarden für Gefängnisse und
Polizei ausgegeben während nur ein
Bruchteil für Programme zur Bekämpfung
der Armut aufgewendet wird die eine der
grundlegendsten
sind die für Kriminalität verantwortlich
ist und solange wir ein
Wirtschaftssystem haben das Knappheit
und Entbehrung bevorzugt und sogar
schafft
wenn die Menschen Zugang zu den
lebensnotwendigen Dingen haben ohne
Knechtschaft Schulden Tausch Handel dann
verhalten sie sich ganz anders
sie wollen dass all diese Dinge ohne
einen Preisschild verfügbar sind wenn
man also keinen Preisschild mehr hat was
motiviert den Menschen dann wenn man
alles bekommt was man will wird man
einfach in der Sonne herumliegen das ist
ein Mythos den sie aufrechterhalten die
Menschen in unserer Kultur sind darauf
trainiert zu glauben dass das Geldsystem
Anreize schaffen wenn Sie Zugang zu
Dingen haben warum sollten Sie dann
etwas tun wollen sie werden Ihren Anreiz
verlieren das ist es was einem
beigebracht wird um das Geldsystem zu
unterstützen
wenn man das Geld aus dem Szenario
herausnimmt gäbe es andere Anreize ganz
andere Anreize
wenn die Menschen Zugang zu den
lebensnotwendigen Dingen haben ändern
sich Ihre Anreize was ist mit dem Mond
und den Sternen es entstehen neue
Anreize wenn man ein Bild malt das einem
gefällt wird man das gerne weitergeben
und nicht verkaufen
Großteil der Ausbildung die ich heute
sehe produziert im wesentlichen eine
Person für einen Job sie ist sehr
spezialisiert sie sind keine
Generalisten die Leute wissen nicht viel
über viele verschiedene Themen ich
glaube nicht dass man Menschen dazu
bringen könnte in den Krieg zu ziehen
wenn Sie viel über viele Dinge wüssten
ich glaube dass es in der Bildung vor
allem um auswendig lernen geht es wird
einem nicht beigebracht wie man Probleme
löst wie man kritisch denkt weder
emotional noch auf seinem eigenen Gebiet
in einer Ressourcen basierten Wirtschaft
würde die Ausbildung ganz anders
aussehen
das Hauptanliegen unserer Gesellschaft
ist die geistige Entwicklung und die
Motivation jedes einzelnen sein höchstes
Potential auszuschöpfen denn unsere
Philosophie lautet je klüger die
Menschen sind desto reicher ist die Welt
weil jeder einen Beitrag leistet
je klüger ihre Kinder sind desto besser
wird mein Leben sein weil sie einen
konstruktiveren Beitrag zur Umwelt und
zu meinem Leben leisten werden denn
alles was wir in einer Ressourcen
basierten Wirtschaft entwickeln würde
auf die Gesellschaft übertragen werden
es gäbe halten würde
Patriotismus Waffen Armeen flotten all
das sind Zeichen dafür dass wir noch
nicht zivilisiert sind die Kinder werden
ihre Eltern fragen habt ihr die
Notwendigkeit von Maschinen nicht
erkannt Papa konntest du nicht sehen
dass Krieg unvermeidlich ist wenn man
Knappheit produziert ist das nicht
offensichtlich natürlich wird das Kind
verstehen dass wir Dummköpfe sind die
nur dazu erzogen wurden den etablierten
Institutionen zu dienen wir sind eine so
abscheuliche kranke Gesellschaft dass
wir es nicht in die Geschichtsbücher
schaffen werden da wird nur stehen das
große Nationen kleinere Nationen Land
weggenommen haben und Gewalt angewendet
haben man wird die Geschichte als
korrupt des verhalten bis zum Beginn der
zivilisierten Welt beschreiben
das war als alle Nationen
zusammenarbeiteten die Vereinigung der
Welt die Arbeit am Gemeinwohl aller
Menschen
ohne dass jemand einem anderen
untergeordnet ist ohne dass die soziale
Schichtung sei es die technische oder
jede andere Art von Elitismus vom
Angesicht der Erde getilgt wird
der Staat tut nichts weil es keinen
Staat gibt
das System für das ich eintrete eine
ressourcenbasierte globale Wirtschaft
ist nicht perfekt es ist nur viel besser
als das was wir haben wir können niemals
Perfektion erreichen
mein Land ist die Welt und meine
Religion ist es Gutes zu tun Thomas pain
[Musik]
die sozialen Werte unserer Gesellschaft
die sich in immerwährenden kriegen
Korruptionen unterdrückenden Gesetzen
sozialer Schichtenbildung irrelevantem
Aberglauben Umwelt Zerstörung und einer
despotischen sozialgleichgültigen
profitorientierten herrschenden Klasse
manifestiert haben sind im Grunde das
Ergebnis einer kollektiven Unkenntnis
von zwei der grundlegendsten Einsichten
die Menschen über die Realität haben
können der im Agenten und symbiotischen
Aspekte des Naturrechts
die im ergente Natur der Realität
besteht darin dass alle Systeme ob es
sich nun um Wissenschaft Gesellschaft
Technologie Philosophie oder irgendeine
andere Schöpfung handelt einem
fließenden fortwährenden Wandel
unterliegen wenn sie nicht gehemmt
werden was wir heute als alltäglich
betrachten wie zum Beispiel moderne
Kommunikations- und Transportmittel wäre
in der Antike und vorstellbar gewesen
ebenso wird die Zukunft Technologien und
soziale Strukturen hervorbringen die wir
uns in der Gegenwart nicht vorstellen
können
wir sind von der Alchemie zur Chemie
übergegangen von einem geozentrischen zu
einem heliozentrischen Universum vom
Glauben dass Dämonen die Ursache von
Krankheiten sind zur modernen Medizin
diese Entwicklung scheint kein Ende zu
nehmen und es ist dieses Bewusstsein
dass uns ausrichtet und uns auf einen
kontinuierlichen Weg zu Wachstum und
Fortschritt führt
statisches empirisches Wissen gibt es
nicht viel mehr ist es die Einsicht in
das Entstehen aller Systeme die wir
erkennen müssen
das bedeutet dass wir jederzeit für neue
Informationen offen sein müssen auch
wenn Sie unser derzeitiges
Glaubenssystem und damit unsere
Identität bedrohen leider hat die
heutige Gesellschaft die es nicht
erkannt und die etablierten
institutionenlähmen weiterhin das
Wachstum indem sie überholte soziale
Strukturen beibehalten
gleichzeitig leidet die Bevölkerung
unter der Angst vor Veränderungen denn
ihre Konditionierung geht von einer
statischen Identität aus und das eigene
Glaubenssystem in Frage zu stellen führt
in der Regel zu Verunglimpfung und
Beunruhigung denn Unrecht zu haben wird
fälschlicherweise mit Versagen das
soziiert obwohl es eigentlich gefeiert
werden sollte wenn man im Unrecht ist
denn es hebt einen auf eine neue Ebene
des Verständnisses und fördert das
Bewusstsein
tatsache ist das ist so etwas wie einen
klugen Menschen nicht gibt denn es ist
nur eine Frage der Zeit bis seine Ideen
aktualisiert geändert oder ausgerottet
werden
und diese Tendenz blind an einem
Glaubenssystem festzuhalten und es von
neuen möglicherweise verändernden
Informationen zu schützen ist nichts
weniger als eine Form des
intellektuellen Materialismus
das Geldsystem erhält diesen
Materialismus nicht nur durch seine sich
selbst erhaltenden Strukturen aufrecht
sondern auch durch die zahllosen
Menschen die dazu konditioniert wurden
diese Strukturen blind und gedankenlos
aufrecht zu erhalten und so zu selbst
ändernden Hütern des Status Q zu werden
Schafe die keinen Schäferhund mehr
brauchen der sie kontrolliert denn sie
kontrollieren sich gegenseitig indem sie
diejenigen ausgrenzen die aus der Norm
fallen diese Tendenz sich dem Wandel zu
widersetzen und bestehende Institutionen
um der Identität der Bequemlichkeit der
Macht und das Profits willen aufrecht zu
erhalten ist völlig unhaltbar und wird
nur zu weiterem Ungleichgewicht
Fragmentierung Verzerrung und
unweigerlich zu Zerstörung führen
es ist Zeit für einen Wandel von den
Jägern und Sammlern über die
landwirtschaftliche Revolution bis hin
zur industriellen Revolution das Muster
ist klar es ist Zeit für ein neues
soziales System das unsere heutigen
Vorstellungen widerspiegelt
das Geldsystem ist ein Produkt aus einer
Zeit in der Knappheit eine Realität war
jetzt im Zeitalter der Technologie ist
es für die Gesellschaft nicht mehr
relevant das anormale verhalten dass es
zur Ausdruck bringt ist verschwunden
auch die vorherrschenden
Weltanschauungen wie zum Beispiel die
theistischen Religionen haben dieselbe
gesellschaftliche Relevanz der Islam das
Christentum das Judentum der Hinduismus
und all die anderen sind Hindernisse für
persönliches und Soziales Wachstum denn
jede Gruppe hält an einer geschlossenen
Weltsicht fest und dieses endliche
Verständnis dass sie anerkennen ist in
einem immer genannten Universum einfach
nicht möglich
dennoch ist es der Religion gelungen das
Bewusstsein für diese Entwicklung zu
unterdrücken indem sie ihren Anhängern
die psychologische Verzerrung des
Glaubens eingeimpft hat bei der Logik
und neue Informationen zugunsten
traditioneller veralteter Überzeugungen
abgelehnt werden
das Konzept von Gottes eigentlich eine
Methode um die Natur der Dinge zu
erklären in der Frühzeit wussten die
Menschen nicht genug darüber wie sich
die Dinge formten und wie die Natur
funktionierte also erfanden sie ihre
eigenen kleinen Geschichten und schufen
Gott nach ihrem eigenen Bild ein Typ der
wütend wird wenn die Menschen sich nicht
richtig Verhalten verursacht er
Überschwemmungen und Erdbeben und sie
sagen das sei eine Tat Gottes
ein flüchtiger Blick auf die verdrängte
Geschichte der Religion zeigt dass sogar
die grundlegende Mythen selbst sich im
Laufe der Zeit durch Beeinflussung
entwickelt haben
ein Beispiel eine zentrale Lehre des
christlichen Glaubens ist der Tod und
die Auferstehung Christi dieser Gedanke
ist so wichtig dass die Bibel selbst
feststellt und wenn Christus nicht
auferstanden ist so ist unsere
Verkündung vergeblich und auch euer
Glaube ist vergeblich es ist jedoch sehr
schwierig diese Darstellung wörtlich zu
nehmen denn es gibt nicht nur keine
Primärquelle die dieses übernatürliche
Ereignis in der weltlichen Geschichte
beliebt sondern das Wissen um die enorme
Zahl vor christlicher Retter die
ebenfalls starben und wieder
auferstanden rückt die Geschichte sofort
in den Bereich der Mythologie
früher kirchliche Persönlichkeiten wie
der tolian bemühten sich sehr diese
Assoziationen zu durchbrechen und
behauptete sogar der Teufel habe die
Ähnlichkeiten verursacht er schrieb im
zweiten Jahrhundert der Teufel dessen
Geschäft es ist die Wahrheit zu
verderben armt die genauen Umstände der
göttlichen Sakramente nach er tauft
seine Gläubigen und verspricht die
Vergebung der Sünden der zelebriert die
Opferung des Brotes und bringt das
Symbol der Auferstehung ein erkennen wir
also die Liste des Teufels an der
gewisse Dinge von denen die göttlich
sind kopiert hat
das wirklich traurige ist jedoch dass
wir wenn wir uns von der Vorstellung
verabschieden dass die Geschichten des
Christentums des Judentums des Islams
und all der anderen wirklich
geschichtlich sind und sie als das
akzeptieren was sie wirklich sind
nämlich rein allegorische Ausdrücke die
von vielen Glaubensrichtungen abgeleitet
sind sehen dass alle Regionen einen
gemeinsamen Nenner haben und es ist
dieses verbindende Gebot des erkannt und
geschätzt werden muss
religiöse Überzeugungen haben zu mehr
Zersplitterung und Konflikten geführt
als jede andere Ideologie allein im
Christentum gibt es 34.000 verschiedene
Untergruppierungen
die Bibel unterliegt der Interpretation
wenn man sie liest sagt man ich glaube
jesus hat dies gemeint ich glaube
johannes hat das gemeint oh nein er hat
das gemeint es gibt also die lutherana
die siebenten Tags Adventisten die
Katholiken und eine gespaltene Kirche
ist überhaupt keine Kirche
und dieser Punkt der Spaltung der ein
Markenzeichen allerteistischen
Religionen ist bringt uns zu unserem
zweiten bewusstseinsversagen
der falschen Annahme der Trennung durch
die Ablehnung des symbiotischen
Beziehung des Lebens
abgesehen von dem Verständnis dass alle
natürlichen Systeme im ergänzend in
denen alle Vorstellungen von der
Realität ständig weiterentwickelt
verändert und sogar ausgelöscht werden
müssen wir auch verstehen dass alle
Systeme in Wirklichkeit erfundene
Fragmente sind nur um der
konversationellen denn in der Natur gibt
es so etwas wie Unabhängigkeit nicht die
gesamte Natur ist ein einheitliches
System von voneinander abhängigen
Variablen jede eine Ursache und eine
Reaktion die nur als konzentriertes
ganzes existiert
man sieht nicht dass der Stecker mit der
Umwelt verbunden ist also sieht es so
aus als wären wir frei und würden
herumlaufen nimmt man den Sauerstoff Weg
sterben wir alle sofort nimmt man das
Pflanzen leben Weg sterben wir und ohne
die Sonne sterben meine Pflanzen wir
sind also verbunden
wir müssen wirklich die Gesamtheit in
Betracht ziehen das ist nicht nur eine
menschliche Erfahrung auf diesem
Planeten es ist eine gesamterfahrung und
wir wissen dass wir ohne Pflanzen und
Tiere nicht überleben können wann fangen
wir also an das wirklich zu
berücksichtigen das ist es was Erfolg
ausmacht Erfolg hängt davon ab wie gut
wir mit allem um uns herum in Beziehung
stehen ich bin mir der Tatsache bewusst
dass mein Enkel nicht darauf hoffen kann
eine nachhaltige friedliche stabile und
sozialgerechte Welt zu erben wenn nicht
jedes Kind das heute in der Äthiopien in
Indonesien in Bolivien in Palästina in
Israel aufwächst die gleiche Erwartung
hat man muss sich um die ganze
Gemeinschaft kümmern sonst wird man
ernsthafte Probleme bekommen
und jetzt müssen wir sehen dass die
ganze Welt eine Gemeinschaft ist und wir
müssen uns alle auf diese Weise
umeinander kümmern es ist nicht nur eine
Gemeinschaft von Menschen es ist eine
Gemeinschaft von Pflanzen Tieren und
Elementen das müssen wir wirklich
verstehen
das ist es was uns auch Freude und
Vergnügen bringen wird das ist das was
in unserem Leben gerade fehlt wir können
es Spiritualität nennen aber Tatsache
ist das Freude aus dieser Glückseligkeit
der Verbundenheit kommt das ist unser
Gott das Geist man kann es tief in sich
selbst spüren es ist dieses erstaunliche
wunderbare Gefühl und sie wissen es wenn
sie es haben man bekommt es nicht durch
Geld man bekommt es durch Verbindung
wenn das keine Gefahr für dieses Land
ist wie sollen wir dann weiter
Atomwaffen bauen müssen Sie was ich
meine
[Musik]
was wird mit der Rüstungsindustrie
passieren wenn wir merken dass wir alle
eins sind
das wird die Wirtschaft ruinieren die
Wirtschaft die sowieso nur ein Fake ist
Wasser ein echter Flop wäre ihr seht
warum die Regierung hat durchgreift
gegen die Idee bedingungslose Liebe zu
erfahren
ich glaube dass die unbewaffnete
Wahrheit und die bedingungslose Liebe
das letzte Wort in der Realität haben
werden dr Martin Luther King Junior wenn
wir einmal verstanden haben dass die
Integrität unserer persönlichen
Existenzen vollständig von der
Integrität von allem anderen in unserer
Welt abhängt haben wir die Bedeutung der
bedingungslosen Liebe wirklich
verstanden
denn Liebe ist Dehnbarkeit und alles als
dich und dich als alles zu sehen kann
keine Bedingungen haben denn in der Tat
sind wir alle alles zugleich
wenn es stimmt dass wir alle aus dem
Zentrum eines Sterns stammen jedes Atom
in jedem von uns aus dem Zentrum eines
Sterns dann sind wir alle dasselbe
selbst ein cooler Automat oder ein
Zigarettenstummel auf der Straße im
Buffalo besteht aus Atomen die von einem
Stern stammen sie alle wurden tausende
Male recycelt genau wie du und ich und
deshalb gibt es da draußen nur mich
wovor sollte man also Angst haben vor
nichts es gibt nichts wovon man sich
fürchten musste denn es gibt nur uns das
Problem ist dass wir getrennt wurden
indem wir geboren wurden einen Namen und
eine Identität bekamen und
individualisiert wurden wir sind von der
Einheit getrennt worden und das ist es
was die Religion ausnutzt dass die
Menschen diese Sehnsucht haben wieder
Teil des großen Ganzen zu sein also
nutzen Sie das aus sie nennen es Gott
sie sagen er hat Regeln und ich denke
das ist grausam ich denke man kann es
auch ohne Religion machen
[Musik]
es ist an der Zeit die Einheit
einzufordern die unsere überholten
Sozialsysteme zerbrochen haben und
zusammen zu arbeiten um eine nachhaltige
globale Gesellschaft zu schaffen in der
für jeden gesorgt ist und jeder wirklich
frei ist
Ihre persönlichen Überzeugungen was auch
immer sie sein mögen sind bedeutungslos
wenn es um die Notwendigkeiten des
Lebens geht jeder Mensch wird nackt
geboren und braucht Wärme Nahrung Wasser
und Unterkunft alles andere ist
nebensächlich daher ist die wichtigste
Frage die sich stellt die intelligente
Verwaltung der Ressourcen der Erde
dies kann in einem monetären System
niemals erreicht werden denn das Streben
nach Profit ist das Streben nach
eigennutzt und daher ist ein
Ungleichgewicht vorprogrammiert
gleichzeitig sind Politiker nutzlos denn
unsere Waren Probleme im Leben sind
technischer nicht politischer Natur
darüber hinaus bedürfen Ideologien die
die Menschheit trennen wie zum Beispiel
die Religion einer starken Reflektion in
der Gemeinschaft über ihren Wert ihren
Zweck und ihre soziale Relevanz es ist
zu hoffen dass die Religion im Laufe der
Zeit ihren Materialismus und ihre
Grundlage im Aberglauben verliert und in
den nützlichen Bereich der Philosophie
übergeht tatsache ist dass die
Gesellschaft heute rückwärtsgewandt ist
und die Politiker ständig über Schutz
und Sicherheit sprechen anstatt über
Schöpfung Einheit und Fortschritt allein
die USA geben heute jährlich etwa 500
Milliarden Dollar für die Verteidigung
aus das ist genug um jeden Highschool
Abgänger in Amerika auf ein vierjähriges
College zu schicken in den 40er Jahren
wurde mit dem Manhattan-Projekt die
erste echte Massen vernichtungswaffe
entwickelt dieses Programm Beschäftigte
130.000 Menschen und war mit extremen
Kosten verbunden stellen Sie sich vor
wie unser Leben heute aussehen würde
wenn diese Gruppe von Wissenschaftlern
anstatt an einer Methode zur Tötung von
Menschen zu arbeiten an einem Weg zur
Schaffung einer sich selbst erhaltenden
Welt im Überfluss arbeiten würde das
Leben wäre heute ganz ganz anders wenn
das ihr Ziel gewesen wäre
anstelle von Massenvernichtungswaffen
ist es an der Zeit etwas viel
mächtigeres zu entfesseln
Waffen der Massen Schöpfung
unsere wahre Göttlichkeit liegt in
unserer Fähigkeit zu erschaffen und
bewaffnet mit dem Verständnis für die
symbiotischen Verbindungen des Lebens
während wir uns von der Natur der
Realität leiten lassen gibt es nicht was
wir nicht tun oder erreichen können
natürlich stoßen wir auf starke
Hindernisse in Form von etablierten
Machtstrukturen die sich weigern sich zu
ändern das Herzstück dieser Strukturen
ist das Geldsystem wie bereits erläutert
ist die Politik der Mindestreserve eine
Form der Sklaverei durch Schulden die
ist der Gesellschaft buchstäblich
unmöglich macht frei zu sein der
Kapitalismus der freien Marktwirtschaft
in Form des Freihandels wiederum nutzt
die Verschuldung um die Welt gefangen zu
halten und die Länder so zu manipulieren
dass sie sich eine Handvoll großer
Unternehmen und politischer Mächte
unterordnen abgesehen von diesen
offensichtlichen amoralitäten basiert
das System selbst auf Wettbewerb der die
Möglichkeit einer groß angelegten
Zusammenarbeit für das Gemeinwohl sofort
zu nicht gemacht und damit jeden Versuch
einer echten globalen Nachhaltigkeit
lähmt
diese Finanz-
natürlich können wir nicht so naiv sein
zu glauben dass die Wirtschafts- und
Finanzelite sich dieser Idee anschließen
wird denn sie würde Macht und Kontrolle
verlieren deshalb müssen friedliche aber
sehr strategische Maßnahmen ergriffen
werden die wirksamste Vorgehensweise ist
einfach wir müssen unser Verhalten
ändern um die Machtstruktur zum Willen
des Volkes zu zwingen
wir müssen aufhören das System zu
unterstützen
der einzige Weg wie das establishmen
sich ändern kann ist dass wir uns
weigern mitzumachen während wir ständig
seine endlosen Fehler und Korruptionen
anerkennen
sie werden das Geldsystem nicht aufgrund
unserer Entwürfe oder unserer
Empfehlungen aufgeben das System muss
scheitern und die Menschen müssen das
Vertrauen in ihre gewählten Führer
verlieren das wird ein wichtiger
Wendepunkt sein wenn das venusprojekt
als mögliche Alternative angeboten wird
wenn nicht fürchte ich die Konsequenzen
die Trends deuten jetzt darauf hin dass
unser Land bankrott geht die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß dass sich
unser Land auf einer Militärdiktatur zu
bewegt um Unruhen und einen
vollständigen sozialen Zusammenbruch zu
verhindern wenn die USA zusammenbrechen
wird es allen anderen Kulturen ähnlich
ergehen
derzeit steht das Weltfinanzsystem
aufgrund seiner eigenen
Unzulänglichkeiten am Rande des
Zusammenbruchs die Währungshüter
erklärten 2003 dass die Zinsen für die
US-Staatsschulden in weniger als 10
Jahren nicht mehr bezahlbar sein werden
das bedeutet theoretisch den totalen
Bankrott der US-Wirtschaft und die
Auswirkungen auf die Welt sind immens im
Gegenzug stößt das auf
mindestreservenbasierende Geldsystem an
seine theoretischen expansionsgrenzen
und die Banken Zusammenbrüche die wir
erleben sind erst der Anfang das ist der
Grund warum die Inflation in die Höhe
schießt alle Schulden auf Rekordniveau
sind und die Regierung und die Fett
neues Geld ausgeben um das korrupte
System zu retten denn die einzige
Möglichkeit die Banken am Leben zu
erhalten ist mehr Geld zu machen die
einzige Möglichkeit mehr Geld zu machen
besteht darin mehr Schulden und mehr
Inflation zu schaffen es ist nur eine
Frage der Zeit bis sich das Blatt wendet
und niemand mehr bereit ist neue Kredite
aufzunehmen während die Zahlungsausfälle
zunehmen weil sich die treffen ihre
laufenden Kredite nicht mehr leisten
können
dann wird die Ausweitung des Geldes
aufhören und eine Schrumpfung in nie
gekanntem Ausmaß einsetzen es hat
bereits begonnen deshalb müssen wir
dieses finanzielle Versagen als das
entlarven was es ist und diese Schwäche
zu unserem Vorteil nutzen hier sind
einige Vorschläge erstens entlarven sie
den bankenbetrug City Bang JP Morgan
Chase und Bank of America sind die
mächtigsten Kontrolleure innerhalb des
korrupten federal reserve-systems es ist
an der Zeit diese Institutionen zu
boykottieren wenn Sie ein Bankkonto oder
eine Kreditkarte bei einer dieser Banken
haben bringen Sie Ihr Geld zu einer
anderen Bank wenn Sie eine Hypothek
haben wie finanzieren Sie diese bei
einer anderen Bank wenn sie deren Aktien
besitzen verkaufen sie sie wenn sie für
Sie arbeiten kündigen Sie diese Geste
wird die Verachtung für die wahren
Mächte hinter dem privaten Banken
Kartell das als Reserve bekannt ist zum
Ausdruck bringen und ein Bewusstsein für
den Betrug des Bankensystems schaffen
kannst schalten Sie die
Fernsehnachrichten aus informieren Sie
sich bei den unabhängigen
Nachrichtenagenturen im Internet CNN MBC
ABC Fox und all die anderen präsentieren
vorgefilterte Nachrichten um den Status
Quo aufrecht zu erhalten da alle großen
Medien von vier Konzernen kontrolliert
werden ist eine objektive Information
unmöglich das ist die wahre Schönheit
des Internets und das ist tabletement
hat wegen dieses freien
Informationsflusses die Kontrolle
verloren wir müssen das Internet zu
jeder Zeit schützen denn es ist im
Moment wirklich unser Retter
drittens erlauben sie weder sich selbst
noch ihrer Familie oder irgendjemandem
den sie kennen jemals zum Militär zu
gehen
es ist eine veraltete Institution die
nur noch dazu dient ein Establishment
aufrecht zu erhalten das nicht mehr
relevant ist die US-Soldaten im Irak
Arbeiten für US-Konzerne nicht für das
Volk die Propaganda zwingt uns zu
glauben dass Krieg etwas natürliches und
das Militär eine ehrenwerte Einrichtung
ist wenn Krieg etwas Natürliches ist
warum gibt es dann jeden Tag 18
Selbstmorde amerikanischer Veteranen die
unter posttraumatischer
Belastungsstörung leiden wenn unsere
Militärs so ehrenwert sind warum sind
dann 25 Prozent der amerikanischen
Obdachlosen Veteranen
viertens hören Sie auf die
Energiekonzerne zu unterstützen wenn Sie
in einem Haus leben verlassen sie das
Stromnetz schauen Sie nach Möglichkeiten
ihr Haus mit sauberer Energie selbst zu
versorgen
Solar oder Wind Energie sind heute für
den Verbraucher erschwinglich und wenn
man die ständig steigenden Kosten für
herkömmliche Energien bedenkt wird diese
Investitionen im Laufe der Zeit
wahrscheinlich billiger sein
wenn sie Autofahren kaufen Sie das
kleinstmögliche und erwägen Sie es zu
einem Hybrid oder Elektroauto umrüsten
zu lassen oder mit etwas anderem als
herkömmlichen Kraftstoffen zu betreiben
5 lehnen sie das politische System ab
die Illusion der Demokratie ist eine
Beleidigung für unsere Intelligenz in
einem monetären System gibt es keine
echte Demokratie es hat sie nie gegeben
wir haben zwei politische Parteien die
sich im Besitz derselben
unternehmenslobbyisten befinden sie
werden von den Konzernen in Position
gebracht und ihre Popularität wird von
den einen künstlich projiziert in einem
System das von Korruption geprägt ist
hat ein Personalwechsel alle paar Jahre
kaum Bedeutung anstatt so zu tun als ob
das politische Spiel irgendeine wahre
Bedeutung hätte sollten Sie Ihre Energie
darauf konzentrieren wie sie dieses
System überwinden können und sechstens
schließen Sie sich der Bewegung an gehen
sie auf ihr seid Geist movement.com und
helfen Sie uns die größte Massenbewegung
für sozialen Wandel zu schaffen die die
Welt je gesehen hat wir müssen jeden
mobilisieren und über die inhärente
Korruption unseres derzeitigen
Weltsystems aufklären zusammen mit der
einzig wahren nachhaltigen Lösung die
alle natürlichen Ressourcen auf dem
Planeten zum gemeinsamen Erbe aller
Menschen erklärt
während wir jeden über den wahren Stand
der Technologie informieren und darüber
wie wir alle frei sein können wenn die
Welt zusammenarbeitet anstatt zu kämpfen
die Wahl liegt bei ihnen sie können
weiterhin ein Sklave des Finanzsystems
sein und den ständigen kriegen
Depressionen und Ungerechtigkeiten auf
der ganzen Welt zusehen während sie sich
mit eitler Unterhaltung und
materialistische Müll zufriedengeben
oder Sie können Ihre Energie auf wahre
sinnvolle dauerhafte ganzheitliche
Veränderungen konzentrieren die
tatsächlich die realistische Fähigkeit
haben alle Menschen zu unterstützen und
zu befreien ohne dass jemand
zurückbleibt aber am Ende muss die
wichtigste Veränderung zuerst in ihnen
selbst stattfinden
die wirkliche Revolution ist die
Revolution des Bewusstseins und jeder
von uns muss zuerst das Trennende
materialistische Rauschen Beseitigen von
dem wir denken es sei echt
schön während wir das Signal das von
unserer wahren empirischen Einheit kommt
entdecken verstärken und darauf
ausrichten
es liegt an Ihnen
was wir in all diesen Diskussionen und
Gesprächen hier versuchen ist zu sehen
ob wir nicht eine radikale
Transformation des Geistes herbeiführen
können die Dinge nicht so zu akzeptieren
wie sie sind sondern sie zu verstehen
wenn sie hineinzugehen sie zu
untersuchen unser Herz und unseren
Verstand mit allem was wir haben
hinzugeben um einen Weg zu finden anders
zu leben
aber das hängt von dir ab und nicht von
jemand anderem denn hier gibt es keinen
Lehrer keinen Schüler keinen Führer
keinen Guru keinen Meister keinen
Erlöser du selbst bist der Lehrer und
der Schüler du bist der Meister du bist
der Guru du bist der Führer du bist
alles
verstehen heißt also zu transformieren
was ist
[Musik]